The interdependency of rowing,
I don't think there's anything quite like it,
at least that I've experienced is this idea that
there's no all-star, there's, there's no,
there's no LeBron James on the team.
(soft music)
There's just a difference between
the best guys and the right guys.
And I was so obsessed with always getting the best guys,
big, tall, strong, how fast you can row
2000 meters on a rowing machine.
Shit doesn't matter out there.
What you need is somebody who's selfless.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today's guest is a beautiful beast of a human.
His name is Jason Caldwell and he is a rather
extraordinary adventure athlete who holds about
a dozen world records across five continents,
including captaining the fastest team
to ever row across the Atlantic ocean unsupported.
(soft music)
And most recently victory in something called
the great Pacific race,
wherein he captained the fastest team to ever row
the Pacific ocean from San Francisco to Hawaii.
And it's a feat Jason and his three teammates accomplished
in just 30 days smashing the previous world record
by an absolutely astonishing nine days.
In addition, Jason is the CEO of Latitude 35,
which is an experiential leadership and high performance
team building consultancy.
He's also a widely sought after public speaker on the
Fortune 500 circuit and has taught at some of the country's
leading business schools
like Wharton, Columbia, Berkeley, and West Point.
He's here today to talk about adventure, of course,
to talk about perseverance,
what goes into tackling audacious goals.
And most importantly,
what his adventures have taught him about leadership about
team-building about cultivating community,
developing human potential,
and really just bringing out the best in others.
So waste another moment we will not
hit that subscribe button
and let's just do the thing. This is me and Jason Caldwell.
Nice to meet you, man. Thanks for doing this.
Yeah. It's a pleasure.
This is, this is an honor for me, so thank you.
Lots to unpack here before we get into anything though,
man, I got to know how the body's healing up.
How you feeling, you look like you put some weight back on.
So I trust that it's all gone well.
Yeah, I'll take that as a compliment, but yeah.
What are we like five weeks since I
six weeks since I did it. So I'm largely better.
First week is nasty. Cause you're learning to walk again.
You've lost 20 plus pounds.
And then you put the weight back on, then the hands hurt.
I had tons of tendonitis,
so that was probably the last thing to come back.
But other than that,
I started training working out last two weeks.
That's been good.
I still have a little bit of numbness
in some of my fingers, like if I do that,
I can still feel that good down
just from just the constant pulling.
But you have that every time, right it comes back.
Yeah well, for the most part, this one,
a couple of these fingers has taken a little while
so its a little.
So 20 pounds you lost.
I think he lost 40 pounds on the Atlantic row right.
Yeah, I think I lost more than that on this one.
they had me stepping on a scale at the beginning that was
in kilos and the another one in Hawaii that was in pounds.
I'm not really sure, but I would say like,
probably it was probably closer to 30,
but definitely not as much as the Atlantic.
Do you do like blood work and stuff to figure out
where you're at specifically before and after?
Yeah, I have.
And we did on this one in fact,
we were working with a company that was,
want us to do blood work and take blood samples
the whole way, the whole way through
so they could analyze it afterwards
because when are they gonna get a chance
to kind of analyze the blood composition
of this type of endurance adventure.
But the thing is we couldn't get blood out of our fingers
out there and I'm not even sure what this is
its either like massive dehydration, but I prick my finger,
I'm sitting in a little tiny cabin,
like rocking back and forth, like squeeze
I can't get--
No blood's coming out.
One little drop, which wasn't enough.
And so I don't--
It's weird.
Too happy.
Yeah I mean,
just trying to wrap my head around what goes into
an endeavor like this is mind blowing.
As I mentioned to you before the podcast started,
I watched the documentary this morning
and I thought I had a sense for the kind of challenges
that you would face and have to endure,
just being wet all the time and the sleep deprivation
and just, what it's like to be on that boat,
but to see all the footage that you had,
and this was chronicling your Atlantic adventures but
just all the sores on your hands
and the sores on the feet and what happens to the seat
and how much your ass is hurt,
like, it just sounds so awful. Its unbelievable.
And I can't remember which teammate of yours,
like you showing how his hands turn into claws and,
you would pry your fingers open and then
they would just close again, no matter what you would do
and the numbness that you get in your fingers.
And the fact that like, after this,
you truly can't walk. Like there's a lot of,
I think it's you wear your calves,
look like your legs look like sticks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So your lats are huge.
Your shoulders are huge. Your chest muscles kind of atrophy.
It all goes away.
Yeah. I mean, yeah, you've nailed it.
It's just, you've become so singular.
So you train for a year or two for this thing
and you train all parts of your body and you're doing
swimming and trail running on top of all the rowing.
But then in the end, it's, it's,
it's pushing with your legs and pulling with your back.
So the chest goes, the calves go,
you take three steps to your rowing seed every two hours
and then three steps back to the cabin
after that's it, and that's it.
So then you just lose the ability to walk.
So I mean like most endurance sports there,
they ruin your body.
I mean, it's not a healthy thing to do.
You get healthy so that you can go ahead and let yourself
get broken down and then rebuild yourself back up.
What are the biggest differences
between rowing the Atlantic versus rowing the Pacific?
Yeah this is, this has been something
I've been thinking a lot about
I mean, right off the bat, the Pacific seemed more violent.
The water's colder, the highs were higher,
the lows were lower.
So that first week in the Pacific was just
coming off of the continental shelf was just brutal.
Yeah we should just say you started,
you started in San Francisco
and you end up in Waikiki basically
Exactly.
And it's like 2100 nautical miles, something like that.
24.
24, okay.
Give me those extra 300--
All right.
Yeah, so it's just,
it just seems a lot more violent like the sea was moodier.
And then the second thing that was obvious
and I'm rolling with two of my teammates
that run the Atlantic as well,
so we all had a good comparison
and it was just constantly changes.
The Atlantic is consistent.
I mean as consistent as an ocean can be,
sometimes you'd get good weather in the Atlantic for three,
four days at a time where it's just that same consistency.
You've got nice little swells that you're surfing down.
You've got good winds,
and you've got kind of the same sea state.
And the Pacific was like every two hours,
it seemed to change it was like,
in some ways it was nice because if you had bad weather,
it's like, well, hey wait two hours, it'll change.
It might get worse, might get better,
but at least it'll be different.
So that was the Pacific.
It was just, it was rougher, more violent, less consistent.
So I think that that was what was apparent to all of us
kind of, as we started rowing.
Its Interesting to hear you say that,
because in watching the documentary,
which chronicles your two Atlanta crossings,
it doesn't look like the Atlantic is consistent.
It looks like it's throwing everything at you
all at the same time where it's constantly shifting.
Yeah. And it is, it's all relative.
There's not really anything such thing as consistency
in the ocean.
I mean, you're in this huge body of water
and you're pretty sure
that at that point, you're, you're personifying the ocean.
I mean, you're giving it human characteristics
cause it seems like it's out to get you.
So whenever you get too comfortable it's,
it changes it up on you.
And we certainly had our fair share of that.
Both the Atlantic crossings you saw on the doc,
but think of this, the Pacific was just,
it was just this idea of,
we have this this world's record that we're trying to break.
We've got a teammate that's,
that's never done an ocean before, but even with that,
we've got seven ocean crossings between three of us
And there, and that's by far the most experienced team.
So you've got this idea where
there's nothing that we haven't seen.
Right.
And so the Pacific will be different,
but it won't be, it won't be dramatically different.
We won't be shocked by anything. And that was wrong.
We were absolutely shocked by stuff out there.
Well, there's so many threads to pull here.
There's the endurance piece. There's the training piece.
Like there's the mindset piece?
How do you get your head around doing something like this?
There's all the experience that you bring to bear to,
put yourself in good stead to accomplish your goals.
And there's the leadership piece and the teamwork piece,
which I think is really interesting here
as somebody who's really an individual athlete.
I mean no, there is no such thing as individual sports,
like anybody who's performing at a high level,
even in an individual sport has a team that supports them.
But there's something very unique and specific
to the sport of rowing that I have really
learned to appreciate just in diving into your story
and how crucial that combination of skill, experience
and comradery comes to play in terms of dictating
whether you're going to be successful or not.
100%, yeah I mean,
I'm looking forward to talking about the team aspect of this
and we'll go off your lead, but
the interdependency of rowing,
I don't think there's anything quite like,
or at least that I've experienced is this idea that
there is no all-star, there's,
there's no, there's no LeBron James on the team,
when you cross the finish line, whether you're doing,
collegiate elite level sprint rowing,
which is 2000 meters, or you're rolling across an ocean,
thousands of miles, you don't cross that finish line
people aren't saying like, oh its that guy that did it.
I mean, you're giving up that, that individualism.
And that's what rowing does
is you're choosing to give up that.
And that's not an easy thing to do
for type a personalities and highly competitive people.
I feel like you perhaps understood that intellectually
before your first Atlantic crossing,
but there was a lot of pride and hubris,
in how you put that team together and where your head was at
in terms of what you thought would happen and unfold.
So talk a little bit about what went
into that first Atlantic.
We're gonna go back and tell your whole backstory but,
that idea of like waltzing into this crazy race,
putting together essentially what was an all-star team
of like the best rowers that you could find
and just thinking, well, these guys are the best.
Like we're gonna, we're gonna crush this thing,
even though we might be missing an experience piece.
Yeah. I mean,
I think the biggest thing when I'm hearing you
kind of frame it like that,
my mind automatically goes to this idea
that half the race you're not rowing.
So you're only two hours on two hours off,
24 hours a day throughout the entire crossing, so--
And let me just stop you right there, sorry to interrupt,
but why is it, why do you arrive at this
two hours on two hours off,
like how did you figure out that that's the best recipe?
Yeah.
This is the golden rule that people are trying
to upend all the time.
Every new team that wants to be competitive
and thinks they've got to figure it out,
tries to change it, including myself, the number of times.
And you just go back to two hours on because,
so let's take, let's take going longer.
Let's say you do three hours on three hours off.
You got to make it consistent.
You're gonna have to spend
the same amount of time off as on so
yeah that's extra time off,
but that third hour is just so unproductive as a rower.
I mean even as a, an elite rower, and highly trained
after two hours you're just not putting lot behind the oars.
There's just, there's just not a lot of purchase there.
And yeah you're getting more, more time resting,
but it's just, it's such an unproductive third hour.
So what you make up for in the extra sleep doesn't pay off
in terms of forward momentum--
I just think--
Behind the, behind the oars.
No, I think there's also a lot of diminishing returns.
Even for the recipe is people think three hours is not a lot
and two hours, is just ridiculous.
But two hours is enough if you do it right.
Doesn't sound like enough.
I know it does not. We'll get into that but
but the third hour is not good.
So then if you, you went the other direction, you said,
okay let's do like an hour on an hour off.
Okay well, there's the obvious thing that
you're only getting an hour of rest,
which that's just not enough to even get some kind of sleep
cause there's other things you're not just getting off
the oars and then falling right to sleep.
You've got to cook food, you've got to drink water.
You got to take care of your body.
You've got to take care of the boat.
But also that's just more shifting, that's more rotation.
So you're doing, on a two hours on two hours off,
you're doing essentially, you're doing
six shifts changes over throughout day yourself.
And if you double that,
it's just more time where people aren't rowing.
And yeah over one day, that's not a lot of time,
but if you're adding an extra,
like three minutes a shift, times six shifts,
times 30 days.
Yeah.
It adds up.
So you're talking about trying to find that happy medium
and two hours I mean, yeah.
You can play around with different things.
You can go maybe and go an hour and a half.
Maybe you can go two and a half hours,
but there's something to be said for consistency
out there too and your body gets into this,
your body gets almost crate trained a little bit
like a puppy its like puppy hates its crate.
Just like you'll hate to go inside that small little cabin
when you're seasick.
But by, by day seven, you're looking forward to it.
It's a place to safety, fall asleep quickly.
Yeah, the body and the mind kind of figure out,
okay, this is what's, this is the program--
Exactly and its amazing.
Now I'm locked in.
let's just keep doing this one thing.
Exactly, so you start to find out that like
two hours of sleep is, or call it an hour and 40 minutes
by the time you get down,
you feel like you can actually get some rest there.
And that's what you come to expect.
So we'll get back to the team building piece,
but just so people understand,
these transoceanic rows are four man crews.
So it's you and three dudes.
You're on a boat where essentially,
at each end, there are cabins.
Two people row a time.
Two people are off and I've heard you talk about
how actually the time off
is more challenging than when you're rowing.
And I suspect that's because when you're rowing,
that's all you're doing. You're just doing this one thing.
It's almost a relief.
All I have to do is row back and forth.
But when you're not rowing,
you gotta take care of yourself.
You gotta mend all your wounds.
You gotta, you gotta feed yourself.
You gotta repair the boat or take care of whatever,
mechanical situations you're dealing with,
you got to get the rest.
There's a lot of stuff to keep track of.
So there's a mental toll to all of that.
Yeah, exactly.
I think that's when you're rowing,
that's what you train for to row.
And so there's something like you said,
it's kind of a relief to know,
okay, I'm on the oars for the next two hours,
this is something I know.
There's a lot of unknown when you're off the,
off the oars and you're having to do things
like feed yourself and take care of your body
and anything that responsibilities on the boat.
But then things come up, you get off course.
Something breaks. Something's not working.
And then all of a sudden,
the time that you were supposed to be sleeping
is now being used to fix something.
And that's the other thing is that you might,
that might be a rest,
but that's only if everything's going right.
The guys that are on the oars are on the oars.
They row they're propelling the boat.
So their only job is to move the boat
in the right direction.
So anything that comes up on the boat during your off shift
is your responsibility.
And, going back to that idea of this first row where
maybe I thought it was going to be
a little easier than it was.
And I think that was what I neglected.
And I see a lot of teams going into the first time.
They don't think about the off shifts.
And I encourage people to spend a lot of time
thinking about the off shifts because it's not just those
responsibilities that I was just talking about,
but mentally you're looking at that clock.
Okay, I've got an hour and 15 minutes,
now I've got an hour and 30 minutes.
Now I've got 47 minutes left and oh my gosh,
I'm not falling asleep right now.
And then you're thinking about that.
So then you're not falling asleep even longer.
And all of a sudden,
you're looking at that little cabin a window
and it's pouring down rain and they look miserable
and you're 20 minutes away
from being out there yourself doing it.
And all of a sudden,
it seems like you can't even finish the next two hour shift,
let alone the next 20 days.
And that, that,
that kind of emotional toll
and mental anguish associated with it is,
that's a pretty powerful de-motivator,
if you haven't like spent time kind of
thinking about that in preparation.
How religious are you about
the two hours on two hours off,
or there's gotta be moments where somebody's sick
or somebody is not feeling it, or you just know,
so-and-so is a little bit weaker today than yesterday.
Do you make adjustments and kind of
read off everybody's energy so that it's more,
a little bit more fluid than rigid?
Or do you just nope, two hours your up.
It's very rigid on our team.
I mean, not every team is like this.
Some teams are just trying to get across
and that's an admirable goal just to do that.
But if you're trying to win a race, set a national record,
maybe even set a world record, you have to be that strict.
Now that being said we have,
and all of our rows have had sick teammates
that can't quite get over the seasickness right away
or injury in which case we decided as a team
that we're gonna take some shifts.
And that happened in this last row.
And it's absolutely the right thing to do.
So then you are making changes and,
I'm gonna row an extra hour.
So I'm gonna do a three hour shift
and then someone else is gonna come on.
But outside of those things, it is a strict two on two off.
And it really is strict.
So if I'm rowing, I've got like three minutes left
until the end of my shifts
I better see light in that cabin go on.
If not I'm gonna give a little knock on it real quick,
because he's got to get ready to go.
And if you think about this way, it's an interesting stat.
My last row was, took us 30 days to cross
San Francisco to Hawaii.
If your teammate was late just two hours
or sorry, two minutes to your shift.
If you had to row just two minutes of his shift,
every shift, which doesn't seem like a lot,
by at the end of 30 days,
you'll have rowed an extra six hours.
That's a half a day of rowing
that you would have taken from your teammate,
just because he's just taking
a little more time to put his shoes on.
So, that's fortunately for our team,
we treat it with respect that it deserves.
And when that time comes up, that person's ready to go.
Right. Right, right, right.
All right so the first time you attempt to do one of these,
I never know what year it is
cause the Atlantic ride takes place over the new year.
So is it 2015, 16.
They call it 2015. Cause we start right at that time.
But yeah, it was 2015/16.
Right so--
As my wife likes to say, by the way,
three weeks after we got married.
Yeah, no right.
In the documentary you get married
and then you just fly to the Canary islands
to like go do this thing, right.
We did go on a honeymoon.
She has no idea what, what is,
she's, she's in store for with this.
No, she's got her own story. That's for sure.
But you spend two years getting ready for this thing.
Right, like studying the maps and trying to figure out
what the strategy is.
And most importantly, recruiting a team.
Yeah.
So talk a little bit about that process
and how that's evolved based on
what you've learned doing this.
Yeah so the first part is the recruitment.
I mean, you can imagine it's a pretty shallow pool
to try to find people that a,
are willing to do this crazy endeavor and spend
a month plus out and away from everything they know,
but then B, the two years of training
and prepping for this thing.
So I rode for a boat club,
Vesper book club in Philadelphia after college
an elite team training for--
A legendary club.
Yeah, I mean it was an honor to be there.
And I spent, I spent three plus years there,
being six foot four, 200 plus pounds,
the shortest and lightest guy on the team.
And so I was a little guy for three years.
I had that complex for a while.
When I got home,
guys didn't like that I was jumping on their backs
because I thought my smaller friends could hold me up.
But, so when I was,
when I was recruiting, I wanted to be at once again,
kind of the smaller guy on the team,
I wanted to get some of these big strong guys,
but I really couldn't find.
Those guys just, they graduated and gone on
started careers, started families.
They're all like Goldman Sachs and stuff.
Exactly. Yeah all the Ivy leaguers.
I was like a little state schooler there, but yeah.
They were all, the opportunity costs
had just risen too much since we left Vesper.
So, I was desperate to find those,
those types of individuals and I got, I got one of them,
a guy that rowed at a different club, but a very good club,
Nick. He was a big strong athlete, but the rest,
Tom and Greg, who I recruited as well
on paper, weren't the, weren't those athletes.
But, I think one of the things I learned about what these,
these other rows after that is there,
there's just a difference between,
the best guys and the right guys.
And I was so obsessed with always getting
the best guys, on paper.
It had to be big, tall, strong, good, 2K scores.
How fast you can run with 2000 meters on a rowing machine,
shit doesn't matter out there.
What you need is somebody who's selfless.
who's thinking about everybody else a little bit more than
they're thinking about themselves.
And those types of process-oriented people.
This is stuff I just didn't know in the first race.
Right.
And there wasn't a lot of ocean experience with these guys.
Like on paper, they had amazing CVs
and were super accomplished rowers on the collegiate circuit
or what have you,
but really didn't have any experience at a race like this.
And it's in the documentary it's,
it's Angus who's kind of like,
yeah we'll see how this goes.
Right. He's he's on the British team.
He's kinda casting a glance over, at your team going
yeah they're talking a big game but,
we'll see what happens when we're out there.
Him being this like sort of master rower
who has all of this ocean experience at the time.
Yeah, exactly. We had zero ocean rowing experience.
Now that's not unheard of, for any of these teams.
I mean, most people have never had done an ocean row.
But people like Angus who have grown up with the sea,
he had actually done a row. He rowed the Indian before that.
So we were running against a guy who's put the team together
and has ocean rowing experience.
But yeah, I mean, he was looking at our team and saying,
yep, they can row in flat water
great conditions for short distances really, really well.
But this is the antithesis of that.
Right.
And so, we yeah,
just this kind of naivete that we went in
and just thinking like,
well it's just like a flat water row.
We just have to do it for a longer period of time was,
was detrimental.
You and you soon found out.
I mean pretty, in pretty short shrift things went sideways.
Yeah so, the first thing that happened was,
we're not even a day out from the Canary islands
where the race starts.
We've got 3000 miles of open ocean to go
and we've got a teammate, Nick,
my biggest strongest teammate that's getting sick,
and seasick.
And, we're all, we're all feeling it for sure.
And it just genetically you're gonna
everyone deals with it differently,
but he was just getting absolutely rattled by it.
And he was not just getting ill,
but as he described, it was like,
like someone was squeezing every angle of his head
and then shaking his head.
So he was disoriented and it just got,
it just kept getting worse and worse and worse.
And, we had, we had by day five or so we had,
this teammate that not only wasn't rowing,
but was very, very ill. So we had that issue.
And then we had another issue with Greg
who just didn't wanna be there anymore.
And that was kind of the, kind of the,
the mental prep that I was talking about just, he was,
he was not willing to make the crossing and...
To his credit, he was rowing his shifts all the way through.
So when we had to get an evacuation where
Nick is being evacuated a week into this row,
Greg saw the opportunity to also leave and took it.
So even though he was healthy, he's like, I'm outta here.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
This is not going good.
Yep. So he was, he was,
he was scared and it's scary out there.
And, and he was, he,
he saw this opportunity cause we're at this point,
we're anchoring.
So we're not, we're not even moving.
We're anchoring for two days waiting for the sailboat
to basically cover the distance
that we'd covered over the last week to come up to us,
it was gonna take them to two days.
So we're anchoring 600 miles off the coast of Africa
watching the last two days.
We know that boats are just getting further and further
away from us knowing that, I know I'm staying so.
Right. But this idea going into it,
that you're gonna, you're aiming to win
you're aiming to break the world record
and suddenly you're in close to last place anchored,
two guys getting carried off your boat
onto a safety sailboat.
I mean the scene in the documentary of getting those guys
off the boat and onto the sailboat was, unbelievable.
It was much more harrowing than I would have thought
like that would be.
Yeah, it was dramatic.
I mean, we've got two guys that are leaving,
but you've got a sailboat that's,
five times the size of our little rowboat
trying to, collect two people,
one of which can barely even move his arms.
He's so sick from the sea, the open sea.
So, we're having to drop them in with their life jackets on,
but like, and they have to pull them in with a rope.
And at one point we lost the guy who was sick.
He couldn't hold on, Nick.
And he was just drifting out there.
And as you probably saw on the dock,
he was interviewed afterwards and said,
that was the only time in his life he's ever been scared.
And you saw him fighting back those tears
as he's watching the film for the first time.
So he's just bringing them right back to where it was.
And this is, as I've said many times before,
he's one of the most tenacious athletes I've ever met,
I mean this guy was nails and--
It just broke him.
Just broke him.
I mean, that's what the ocean does.
So suddenly your four man boat turns into a two man boat
and then you and Tom decide like, all right,
well we're just gonna, we're gonna just keep going.
Just the two of us.
Yeah. It was not as easy as we're just gonna keep going.
Tom took some convincing. I knew I wasn't gonna leave.
And Tom's one of my closest friends. He was in our wedding.
This is a guy I've worked with for years.
And my last pick on the team, by the way, because,
you saw from the doc, he's not a big guy.
I mean he's tall, but he's skinny,
has trouble putting on weight and muscle.
And--
But he looks,
by the end of the thing, he looks like a marathon runner.
Yeah, yeah, yeah he does.
And he's just, I mean, he didn't,
he couldn't lose any more weight than he had already lost.
I mean, it was starting to get really like, kind of,
that's why he's having back problems by the end of it
and stuff I think it was just, I mean,
I think that that row was eating into like his muscle
and tendons and stuff, but.
He didn't, he wasn't sure he wanted to stay right away,
but he finally got convinced.
And so, he stayed on and once the evacuation had worked,
I just have this vivid memory of just seeing that boat
sailing off literally into the horizon,
heading to the Verde islands.
And we're just, and they're getting smaller
and we're just bobbing, we haven't started rowing.
We're just, the boats just bobbing up and down.
And we're seriously trying to figure out, like, what is our,
like what is our strategy here?
We're 2,400 miles away from the finish,
we're in a boat made for four or five people.
Now gonna be rowed by two.
Yeah. And your goals are out the window.
So you need something else to kind of anchor your focus.
Yeah. Yeah, what was that motivator?
And I think we had a conversation about it.
I think what we decided was to prove everyone wrong
because there were people that said like,
we have a responsibility to get off the boat as well,
because this can't be done with just two people.
This, like they said,
this boat's meant for four or five people.
This is just, this is, this is irresponsible.
And you're other competitors at risk.
Because if you do need a second rescue,
that means resources diverted away from
somebody else's boat.
Exactly.
If they needed help.
Yep. If, one of the safety boats is closest,
they're gonna have to divert their route to get to us,
which could strand other boats.
Also maritime law requires that any other vessel out there,
even if it's a big shipping freighter that has the ability
to rescue us and is close must divert their route to come.
And so there were people that were saying
it's inevitable that that's gonna happen.
So you're gonna just,
you're gonna waste time and resources
and money from somebody.
So it was irresponsible for us to stay on.
I never once saw it that way.
And I mean, when you choose a life of adventure
and endurance rowing you're constantly gonna have
to convince people that what you do
is not irresponsible and selfish,
even though to a certain extent it is.
But that's my big, that's my big argument.
So it was what, what is gonna get us through.
Because one of the things that, and this is,
we're talking about lessons learned from this first crossing
is one of the ones I learned is that,
glory kind of takes you to that start line.
The thought of doing something that no one else has done
and you get these pats on the back
when people hear that you're gonna do this,
and you've got sponsorship that's behind you.
And, a charity that's behind you.
And all of a sudden
you're feeling pretty good about yourself.
But that glory will not get you to the finish.
When you were bobbing up and down in a boat
with just you and one other guy,
600 miles off the coast of Africa with 2,400 miles ago,
those pats on the back and all that stuff
that is not what's gonna get you across.
And we spent too much time kind of soaking that in
and not time trying to understand what gets somebody across
some, an extremely difficult distance such as an ocean.
And what I found out is, it's shame.
It is being more afraid of letting down your teammate,
who's in the boat, your family who's rooting for you,
your charity, your sponsors, your friends, your family,
your community, being more afraid of letting them down
than you are of the elements, than you are of dying,
than you are of,
being scared of getting drenched that night.
And that shame is what gets, what got us through.
It was, what I call later, because shame is not a great
word to be using because as it's a
kind of leveraging of human emotions.
And that's what we did, we leverage each other's
human emotional way that we were more afraid
of letting each other down than we were the elements.
Yeah, at the same time you also had to find a way
to be of mutual support to each other, right.
So you have this experience where you're rowing
and Tom's like, what do you want for breakfast, right.
Like that was, that feels like it was sort of
an inflection point in terms of how you guys
were gonna interrelate to each other and support each other,
but even more broadly,
a lesson in regards to kind of teamwork and leadership.
Generally, yeah it was a huge point
that we didn't notice then.
It wasn't until afterwards that we realized
how pivotal that moment was because we're,
we had been rowing with for
about five or six days by ourselves.
And we were still doing two hours on two hours off,
by the way but instead of being with somebody on deck,
you're by yourself.
So you're rowing two hours while the other guy's getting
some sleep and one of the cabins and then you're rotating.
So there's all this kind of solitude.
I mean, just think about five days of,
we're chatting with each other
every two hours just in passing.
And so we get pounded by this storm
and it's just, it's just relentless.
And this is where you start to think that,
that the ocean is out to get you.
And so for three days, which just get pounded by the storm,
and I'm gonna be honest with you
like at the end of the third day,
I just I wanna quit, I do, I wanna quit.
And I'm mad that I allowed us to stay out there,
and I feel guilty for convincing Tom to stay out there
because he's not doing well.
And that's where we have this kind of without hope or agenda
this breakfast moment where he's about to come on his shift.
It's like, I have like the 6:00 AM to 8:00 AM shift.
And he's about to come on that shift and get ready at eight.
And instead of like coming on, he just asked me like,
what I'd want for breakfast.
And I remember like at that moment being upset with him
for asking such an insensitive question.
Because up to this point,
kind of the guy that was coming on shift would kind of offer
the words of encouragement, empathy.
And, that's what I was living for, my lowest moment,
probably my whole life at this moment is my lowest.
I'm thinking, the dark thoughts of wishing I could quit.
And I wonder if there's a boat close enough and I'm gonna
that's what I'm thinking.
I can't get those thoughts out of my head.
And he asked what I want for breakfast.
And I kind of just play along with it a little bit
and just tell them what my favorite freeze dried meal,
which is the chicken risotto.
And he says, well, I like the spaghetti bolognese.
And we're having this conversation he says,
you want me to make you some coffee?
And I'm like, yeah, sure.
He's like, do you want me to put the
powdered hazelnut creamer?
And I love that stuff. So I said, yeah sure.
And he, he makes a deal.
This is the deal he makes me
says if you row an extra 10 minutes,
like I'll make some food for you.
And I'm aware at this point,
this is 10 minutes of his shift.
Yeah.
An your vulnerable.
Yeah, I'm like a little bit like,
where's he going with this?
But I hate making the food and he knows that
I don't like to do the jet boil,
I'd rather put the muscle into the oars
and he'd rather cook than row.
So, we, I make the deal and, and sure enough,
after some time he, he says,
I got some food for you and we turn around
and I stopped rowing.
And again, we don't even, we're not trying to,
this isn't planned.
But I pulled the oars in
and we just have that breakfast together.
And something really dramatic takes place.
That's, kind of like a subtle but traumatic shift in
kind of the mentality of the boat.
We just, we just hang out.
We're just two buddies at that point,
sharing stories of what's happened to us
the last three nights.
Cause we've been by ourselves
and we're kind of desperate to share with somebody.
So we just kind of just talk and all of a sudden
we could be, we could be at home, talking in one of our,
on our living rooms or something like that.
It's just, there was this comfort that washed over us.
And from that, it was 30 minutes or whatever.
And then we went back onto our shifts.
But from that moment on, for the next 41 days,
we always did breakfast.
It was just something that we could look forward to.
And again, didn't know it at the time, but looking back,
it was just a way for us to kind of re-answer the question
why we were doing this.
It's like have that glory idea at the beginning.
that is not gonna get you through no one.
You don't care anymore,
that people are excited for you to finish,
its just not pulling you through.
But I sure as shit care that the guy
that's sitting 20 feet away from me
is going through a tough time.
And if I could just roll a little harder for him
on this shift and he comes out and he sees
that I put four miles in instead of three,
that'll make him happy and he'd wanna do the same
because he won't want to let me down.
So it was just as back and forth for the next 41 days
of just trying to live up to the other person.
And it was just,
the ante just kept getting higher and higher.
And breakfast was a way to kind of
realign ourselves every 24 hours.
I mean if your just ships passing in the night.
And the only exchange that you have is when one's getting,
off the chair and the other one's getting in,
you're not gonna be in sync.
Like you've got to be aligned, emotionally
and check in with each other when you're working
towards this goal otherwise there's no way.
I mean, the ship would quite literally capsize.
Yeah. It's exactly what it was.
And that kind of realignment was,
and that breakfast was our way of just kind of
realigning ourselves and kind of reminding ourselves
of why we're doing this.
By looking someone else in the face that you could see,
man the last 24 hours beat you to shit.
You can see it in his face, and he could see it in mine.
And I was so proud of him,
because Tom is, to this day,
he's my close friend, we work together.
But I just, he had no business being out there.
We had, we worked together in old company.
One of the guys I worked there actually,
our boss said, you should cut Tom from the team.
He's not, he's not built for this.
And I remember considering it because
the guy that was saying this,
our boss was a former Olympian. He knew rowing.
And I'm so glad I didn't,
because he on paper was not the right guy,
but absolutely the right guy for this boat.
And I just was so afraid to let him down.
And I knew that he needed me to put the muscle in and I did.
And he was so afraid to let me down.
He cooked for me and he'd,
he'd get bandages out for me when I,
when I had infection.
And he's like, cause I know you're not gonna take care
of yourself Jay, so let me help you do it.
It's just this, this brotherhood.
And it was,
quite frankly,
kind of one of the most amazing things ever happened to me.
Yeah. You end up passing a bunch of boats,
you ended up finishing,
you going for, you go from almost last to 11th. Right.
You get 11th in that race took you 51 days.
Yeah.
But I feel like that was you getting a masters in,
what you needed to know to go back and,
have a more, a more perfect attempt.
And it had nothing to do with how you trained for it.
Like all the stuff that you would think like, okay,
back to the drawing board, like we need to change this,
we need to change that.
It was all about the emotional piece, right?
Like extrapolating on that breakfast experience
and the guy who, was healthy, but got, decided to leave.
Like you go back to the drawing board and you're like,
I got to solve this through a different lens.
Yeah. And just even to take it once,
take a step back is that,
I didn't have no plans on doing the second time.
Even if I didn't win, I was,
I thought this is a one and done type of thing.
I mean, so few people have ever even attempted a second one.
Most of those people are because
they didn't finish the first time.
they made it so many days they had to call out.
They don't wanna try to do it again.
Like for us to finish was still a great thing.
But like, I couldn't shake the sense of failure.
And I even, I say this in the doc, but it's so true.
It's like, I remember the juxtaposition between
my emotional state and Tom's emotional state
as we are coming into the finish line,
seeing everybody on the cliffs,
seeing our families that we come in and see was just,
he was giddy. He was beside himself. He was so excited.
And I did, I felt like I was acting to be as giddy as him.
I did feel that way.
Because I think--
Meaning you didn't really feel that way.
You felt like you had failed.
Or what was the, what was your interior?
Yeah, I don't know if I,
I don't know if I would have defined it as failure yet.
Although I did later and I still do today as a,
as a captain, as a leader, I had failed that team.
But at that moment, I just felt this idea.
Like, I felt like maybe I was only halfway done.
And from like this,
that I was gonna have to do another one.
And Tom, I knew it was never gonna do another one.
It wasn't it for him.
He had nothing left to prove.
You see, you see the pictures of him, you know that.
But there we both, we both entered for different reasons,
and he had proven everything he needed to prove to himself
and to anybody else to doubt him.
But I had something left to do.
So that's, that was what happened
is stepping off as I didn't feel the closure.
Well, let's, let's spend a few minutes there
and maybe this is a good time to like,
take it back a little bit because I'm interested in,
in that internal drive that you had.
As somebody who had been successful as an athlete,
but had never really had the victories that you sought.
Right, like it was always like,
you were the guy who came in second
or had an opportunity to do something great,
but something would happen and you wouldn't quite
connect with it.
So there's this, kind of cauldron inside of you,
this sense that you have something to express,
and yet kind of repeated frustrations with
your ability to execute on that.
Yeah. It was wall full of silver medals
as I like to call it.
That's really what I felt like I was.
To include where we are here in this story
of finishing this first row its...
Played baseball in high school,
played in college, got injured.
I was a left-handed pitcher, needed to--
But even before that, sorry to interrupt, but like,
let's take it back to your dad.
Because I feel like your dad,
your dad put some heat on you. Right?
Like this guy was expecting, some exceptionalism out of you.
Yeah. My dad was,
him and I are we're close and still are very, very close.
And, but he was a guy that took you by your word.
If you said you wanted to do something, if like,
if you said you wanted to be a professional baseball player,
he's like even if you said it at seven years old,
he wasn't placating you.
And he's like, okay, you said it now, now we're gonna,
now we're gonna see what you're really made of.
Thank goodness I didn't say I want to be an astronaut
because I think he would have been putting me through
that kind of training.
But, being a ballplayer himself, growing up,
this was his wheelhouse.
And so it was, I felt as a child constantly proving
that I was doing what was necessary to be the best.
And, if I wasn't showing it on the, on the ball field,
then I wasn't doing it off the field to make it happen.
It wasn't, there was no such thing as a bad game.
It was just ill prepared.
And so, yeah, there was a lot of,
a lot of pressure and even going into college
and playing there was an expectation there.
And I wasn't meeting those expectations.
And even like, even the injury to be fair,
to be very honest and we're being honest here is that
it was probably, there was a little relief.
There was a, there was a relief when that injury happened.
And I could have gotten the surgery and believe me
my dad wanted me to, he says, you get the surgery,
you take a year off, you rehab.
And then you go back in, yeah.
You had the Tommy John elbow thing. Right.
Just the torn tendon.
And it was like,
I remember him being so surprised when I said,
I need time to think about whether
I'm gonna get this surgery.
And, cause we got the MRI results that day and he says, oh,
there's nothing to think about. You get it.
And you pursue your dreams at all costs.
And I, while I agree with that mentality,
I just don't think I was in the right sport.
I didn't know it at the time.
And I was told I loved baseball
and I was passionate about the sport.
But I realize now that I liked baseball,
but I, when I got into rowing,
I realized what love was.
So--
You needed that,
that backdoor exit.
I did. And I took it and,
and it, it, it, again, these are all things that you,
you process later in life.
Because when I hurt myself in baseball,
I was in my mid twenties and I didn't know anything but.
So how was dad when you said I'm not getting the surgery?
Yeah. He was not happy.
And we didn't talk for a little while too.
Cause I remember specifically, it wasn't a,
like F you F you and having a blow and I slammed the door
and go back to college and never talked to him again.
But it was just like all of a sudden,
we just didn't pick up the phone to call each other.
And it wasn't, that is dramatic.
It's just, cause I remember
'cause I got a younger brother
and his birthday's in September.
And I remember going home for that.
The, this is the first year back,
not playing baseball at Sonoma state.
And I had gotten into rowing since then,
because school started in August.
I got recruited by the rowing coach. I'm loving it.
I'm finding I'm pretty good at it.
And I remember going to that family birthday
we'll pool party and tell my dad,
like I got into rowing and like,
this is the first time I'm telling him this.
So I know we hadn't talked for awhile.
And it took him a long time to get on board.
But to his credit, he did.
But I'll tell you what,
he didn't know what was going on the first,
little side note, he didn't know
what was going on the first, regatta.
Because first of all, my mom was always championing me
cause I'm her only kid and she's,
annoyingly optimistic about everything first.
Firstly she's always late to everything.
So she went from a sport that takes three hours to play
to a sport that takes six minutes to complete.
So she like miss my first regatta
showed up too late, missed it.
My dad, meanwhile, gets to a regatta
with my two little brothers first time,
this is that year, the first year he's like, okay,
Jason's in a new sport. We're gonna support them.
This is his new thing. And I appreciate that.
And he gets there and he sees tense line in the river
and free food on all of them.
So he's just sending my brothers through the ringer,
getting bagels, and then he doesn't realize it
until like some nice parents like,
oh, these are actually for all
these are, this is actually for, this is for Cal Berkeley.
What school does your kid go to?
Sonoma state.
Oh, it's that one that's leaning against the Ravi.
Every tents for a different...
He's like oh great free food.
These are awesome.
So, I'm bringing my family into a new world.
That's pretty funny, man.
I just watched a,
I was on an airplane the other day and I watched
"Molly's Game" on the flight. Have you seen that?
Yeah. Its a great movie.
So I'm seeing a lot of parallels here a little bit.
Yeah. Yeah, of course.
She jumps into a new arena.
Right? Exactly.
It takes all that fire and just applies it elsewhere.
But you didn't, I mean,
this happens your senior year in college, right?
So you actually only row collegiately one year then.
Well, I did.
And then I got accepted to Vesper summer program
right after my first year of rowing.
How did that happen? Because only one year in a boat.
Yeah. It was--
When you're going up against dudes
that have been doing this for--
Since as long as I've been playing
as long as I've been playing ball.
Yeah. So, I mean, that's a,
that's an interesting story
because I've got a collegiate coach
who's trying to build a program at a no-name rowing school,
Sonoma state.
I mean they hadn't even won to race
when I come onto the team, right?
This is hardly head of the Charles.
This isn't, this isn't,
this isn't Harvard versus Princeton.
Sonoma State's a no name rowing program clubs, sports.
So it doesn't get any hardly any funding, but,
but this coach understands how to build teams.
He's my first true mentor and how to build teams.
And he went to every sport at Sonoma state
and said give me a list of the guys you cut
the guys that got injured and I'm gonna go off those lists.
Talk to me about them.
Cause I'm looking for a specific thing.
My name was on the baseball list as someone who got injured.
And he was looking for people that no longer were part of
something greater than themselves, so to speak.
And he was gonna go and offer them.
He was saying, I'm not offering you--
But also the people who are looking
for what the next thing might be.
and had a bit of hunger.
Exactly and I,
I made that list and he approached me in the weight room and
I was a little like concerned by how much he knew about me.
But he convinced me to go to this, to rowing.
And shortly thereafter, I,
I started falling in love with the sport, but that was he,
he knew that he just needed to put
a bunch of special people together and let,
create an environment that they could win.
And all of a sudden, guess what we started winning.
We didn't just give Sonoma state their first,
when we gave them their first six.
And we have a little special team,
just enough to gain some interest from some school,
boathouses back east, Vesper being one of the best,
if not the best elite rowing team in the country.
They had just gotten a new coach, Michiel Bartman
three time Olympic medal winner in three different Olympics
for the Netherlands, just retires at 40
after winning his last medal, in Athens.
Gets the job as the head coach.
Moves from the Netherlands to Philadelphia.
Now he's responsible for putting,
the next grade team together at Vesper.
And they offer 12 to 16 spots max for that team.
And my coach at Sonoma state Mark,
got to give them credits, calling every boathouse there.
I mean, they're not, he's not even getting any calls back.
I mean, Sonoma state's a no-name school
and he's telling them I got this one guy
you're gonna want him. You're gonna want him.
But no, one's no one's biting, but Michiel calls back.
And Michiel's interested in my baseball history.
He thinks that,
if a guy that could have played at this level,
that maybe I can turn them into a rower.
And what we didn't know, I found out later
because Michiel becomes another mentor of mine
and one of the greatest coaches I'll ever know is he,
he loves baseball.
In Netherlands one time when he was in high school,
some ex U.S. pro came into batting practice
on his, on his field
and he just fell in love with the sport.
And so he said, let's give him a try.
So I show up to this boat house knocking on the door.
First guy that answered the door, 6'7"
like, oh man, I am out of my league.
And I, there was a moment I thought about
maybe I should just duck and run,
like just not even go to this first practice.
And Michiel says, basically, don't get too comfortable.
Like we'll see what you can do.
Yeah.
Basically I spent that entire summer just getting
my ass kicked up and down the school court river.
He enters me in the toughest races and in the single.
So I'm I a, I'm I'm in a single, just getting,
I'm just getting my kicked, but I got better real fast.
And so at the end of that summer, he said,
Michiel said look, you're not,
you're not good enough to make the year round team here,
but let me go ahead and get you into Penn,
which was two doors down the Ivy league school.
Let me just get you in there.
And then you can row at Penn next year
and I can keep an eye on you.
And then, let's try it again next year.
Cause I think there's something here.
But I told him like, if it's all the same to you,
I'd like to go back to Sonoma and row with my boys
over there, which he thought was crazy, but he let me do it.
And I went back to Sonoma,
enrolled as a geology master's program.
So just to let you know, Rich,
I've got one year under my belt as a master's in geology.
You know a little thing about rocks.
Rocks for jocks, you know?
And I, so I was able to run another year college there.
So you did a year there and then you went back.
Yeah so I got a second year rowing at Sonoma,
just staying eligible.
I see.
There just cause I knew I needed,
I needed to get more, basically more strokes under my belt.
So then I went back to Vesper the next year
and made the year round team.
Yeah. So what did you do during that year in Sonoma
that allowed you to make that leap?
Was it just more time in the boat and experience
and just the grind?
It was that, but I was also,
this is my journey and to becoming a better leader.
That first year at Sonoma,
I had a chip on my shoulder,
I was too good for this sport kind of
sometimes too good for these guys.
And I played baseball and I was in an elite athlete
and I'm getting to this sport and this is a rag tag team
of hand-me-down equipment and all this kind of stuff.
And I made good friends with a couple of the guys,
but for everybody else,
it was just kinda like the mentality that my dad has
was like, prove to me that you're worthy
of being in this boat with me.
When I get to Vesper for that one summer
and between those two years at Sonoma,
I realized that that is not the type,
the type of leaders on Vesper were different guys.
They were, they were selfless guys.
They weren't necessarily even the biggest and fastest guys
that were well-respected on that team.
They were just these guys that everyone can count on,
no matter what happened when they were in the boat,
the boat went faster.
It had nothing to do with how fast I could pull 2000 meters
on the rowing machine or how much they could bench press
or or leg press.
It was just when, when, when Jaime went in the boat,
the boat was faster when you took them out of the boat,
whoever you put in, it went slower.
And I started to realize that there was this sense of
when you were, someone was in the boat that you respected,
you wanted to pull harder for them.
They didn't have to pull harder.
It's just the, it's the seven other guys in the boat
that said, hey, Jaime is in this boat.
We love this guy. And let's pull hard for him.
And everybody, and that's the force multiplier
of rowing is that you don't need to pull harder
you just need to leverage the human emotion of everyone else
so that they pull harder.
But you also have to work like a single organism, right?
There's like this heavy symbiosis that has to occur.
So if somebody is way stronger than everyone else,
that's great.
But if the energy's off and you're not kind of congealed
into this unit, it's not gonna work, right.
I mean, I say that as somebody who knows very little
about rowing but it seems like that would be the case.
Yeah.
I mean, complete interdependency and swinging together.
And this idea that when you, the boat
and that's, what's great about rowing and,
is when you are rowing well together, the boat gets lighter
it gets easier.
You can actually feel like you could row that way forever.
And so that's what you're aiming for,
every rower is trying to feel that swing, that flow,
that means that everybody is rowing together.
And so that's, that was the second piece of it is that
great rowers could assimilate to the rest of the team.
They didn't force people to row like them.
They gave up that individual ego for the collective ego
and they rode like everybody else.
Right.
So you don't hear of these great individual champions.
I think it harms the sport in terms of
like mainstream visibility,
because we don't have big names that we can rally behind
because it's such a team thing.
But I think in the conversation around like
great endurance athletes, like nobody's harder than rowers.
Like these guys, basically just destroy themselves.
Like you hear about cyclists and marathon runners,
et cetera, and all of that.
But like rowers are like the anonymous heroes
in the endurance world who grind like
no other athletes I've ever met.
That's well said.
I've been in running a lot longer than you have
and I haven't ever said it that well.
I feel like, I feel like, I feel like they don't get it
they don't get enough deserved kind of attention
and accolades for what goes into
being great at that sport.
But I also, I agree,
and I also think that's what makes the sport so great.
And there's a certain allure to that.
And I think you, when you hear about great rowing teams,
that's exactly how they're called.
They're called the crew of 87 or, Vespers crew of 06
or whatever it is.
It's not LeBron and Michael Jordan.
Exactly. It's this, it's the crew.
And that's the word is, the crew, that's the noun.
Rowing's the verb and crews the noun.
And so, but there is something,
if you can get over that individual kind of ego of it all,
which by the way, is very difficult to do.
If you can't--
Cause you need ego, but it's the humility piece that,
that like is the distinguishing factor
to make a champion crew.
And by the way, the people that will know who did it
is the rest of the team.
Cause you're the, you're spending hours and hours and
thousands of meters rowing together,
but you're also spending time on the docks.
You're spending time together.
I mean, Vesper was a work hard play hard place.
We rowed twice a day together with two practices a day,
usually a weightlifting session in the middle.
And Saturday night because there was no practice on Sunday
that's the night you go out.
Yeah sure.
So you're going out,
with 10 other guys and you taking care of each other,
Philly's not an easy place.
And when 12 big guys going to a bar
or something like that trouble ensues.
And, but it's the guys that take care of each other.
It's like a seal team six kind of vibe, right?
Yeah. Except for, we're not as tough as those guys.
But it is, it is definitely that way.
It's this, it's this idea.
And how there's this guy, there was this guy at Vesper,
I know we're getting a little on a little bit of a tangent,
but I think it's important.
There was this guy, the first summer Vesper's really
what brought me to go to Sonoma the second year.
Don wiper never forget him, went to Dartmouth.
I'm there, I'm a, wide-eyed novice rower.
I'm pretty sure that these guys think,
why am I even on this team?
They're being nice to me, but they're not,
they're not including me in a lot of stuff
and I probably would have done the same.
But you weren't getting beat up by some Winkle vie.
No, no. In fact, I was usually the enforcer down the road.
I was the, I was the guy doing all the, the rough housing.
If we got into trouble out there, as I'm sure we did,
those stories are for another time.
But this guy, Don,
he was the stroke seat of the top boat at Vesper.
And he's not the biggest guy.
Doesn't have the fastest 2K, and no one can beat him.
No one can beat him out of that spot.
And the, the stroke seat, which is eight seat,
that's like the quarterback of the team.
That's, the guy.
You were largely considered to be
the best rower on the boat.
He's not the biggest guy, not the strongest guy.
Doesn't come from the best school.
Dartmouth's a good school but in the IVs,
they get up, they get beat up by the Princeton,
Harvard's and Yales and no one could beat him.
And one day I just asked him, like, how do you do it?
I'm, I'm pretty much, I'm pretty certain
this is my last summer first and last summer at Vesper.
Might as well get as much as I can out of this.
I asked him one day in the weight room,
I was like, how do you do it?
Like, what are you doing to keep you there?
Now, one of the things is to find out
who as an individual is faster in a rowing boat,
you row two boats for a length of time
called two-minute side-by-side.
You measure the distance that they got from each other.
You record that distance, a coach as well.
Then you take one person from each boat,
you swap them and you row them again the same distance.
And you see what the change was.
That's how you find out how the individual
is adding to the speed of the boat and Don.
And that's called seat racing.
And Don would never lose a seat race, never.
This guy, no matter who he was going against,
he would always beat him.
And I said like, how you always win the seat races?
He says, oh, I just set the boat up.
I barely row, I let everyone else win for me.
And that was when I started to understand this idea
that if everybody that you're
or the boat you're going into loves respects you
feels they owe you something
they will win the race for you.
And that's what he was doing.
He was the guy that would row extra mileage
at the end of practice cause someone needed some extra work.
Always be the guy spotting you at the gym,
picking you up from the bars if you were,
you're out a little late, not letting the coach know,
all this kinds of stuff, he was a players player.
He earned that trust and that loyalty over time.
And it was amazing.
And the, that was measurable out on the water.
That's an interesting thing that you can measure his loyalty
by the distance he would put between his boat
and the boat that was behind him that he just got out of.
And that was my first little like insight into
what it meant to be a real leader.
Yeah.
So you're getting this, this master's in geology,
but really what you're doing is you're,
you're getting, you're getting, it's sorta like
I got a master's degree and everything I needed to know
about team building and leadership
while sitting on a rowboat.
Exactly.
Right.
That's exactly what I'm doing.
That's the title of your next book, right?
So you go, you go back to Vesper,
and what's the goal like the Olympics,
like what's, what's the, you know.
Yeah, I think everyone's goal going to a place like Vesper
as an elite is to, make the national team
or the Olympics or both.
And, and so that's, that's why you're there.
I mean if you're not there for that reason,
you're probably not gonna last very long.
But again, my second one--
Well other than that what is there,
because it's not like you're,
making any money doing this.
You're out of college and this is your life.
Yeah. I mean, that is what it is.
I think there's sometimes you'll see a guy
who come from a pretty prestigious school
and you'll think, well, this guy serious,
he's gonna be a force.
And then he's just not that good.
You can realize that his heart's not in it.
Maybe he just wants to continue to live out
the glory days of his collegiate rowing.
And he doesn't make it that long.
Coach will cut them fast because he just it's
the demand on your time and on your body
is just too much to not have something like
the Olympics or the national team in your sights.
So yeah, we're all there.
The guys that are on the year round team
are there for that reason.
And it's a, it's a brotherhood,
it's a fraternity at that point.
And we're living in these,
this old historic boathouse anyway,
and that's what we're practicing every day.
And, so it's, it's a fraternity.
And so what the end game is,
is that some of us will make it and some of us will not.
That's, what's kind of--
So how does this play out for you?
Well, I spent about three years there,
go from this obscure baseball player slash rower
who probably shouldn't even be there, moved my way up into
the second boat and finally make my way
into the first boat.
And for me to do that--
I mean that's some pretty incredible progression
for somebody who's still pretty new to the sport.
Yeah. Thank you.
A couple of years to go,
from a guy who it's almost like they were doing a favor
to let you kind of tag along
to being in the number one boat.
Yeah, I know.
That's, one of my prouder moments
is making that team and, I worked hard to get there
and I think, Michiel took a chance on me
because by accepting me on that team,
somebody else didn't get accepted.
And that person has probably been rowing
a lot longer than me.
Was probably a lot faster than me on the water,
but Michiel saw something and I mean,
I'm not gonna argue with that because I felt that
first time I did not feel I deserve to be there,
but the second summer I did because I learned so much.
And so I worked my way up over the last,
over the next two and a half years to,
to get into that top boat.
And I remember the frustration of my,
my last summer there trying to get into that first boat
and Michiel was the coach of the women's team there too.
And that year they had a,
a women's lightweight double that was going
to a world championships. So he was focusing on them a lot.
And so he had another one of the coaches,
collegiate coach running our day-to-day practices.
He'd pop in a few times a week and run the practices
but for the most part, we had to answer to this guy.
And I would be seat raced.
I'd be switched, I'd win every one of my seat races.
And I'd still, when the lineups came up the next morning,
I would not be in that top boat.
And I was just getting pissed.
And now I'm friends with these guys,
I'm close with everybody.
And at this particular summer, that's when the,
they infuse it with the summer kids.
These are kids that are still at universities,
Princeton's Harvard Yales.
And I'm beating this Princeton guy,
every time for this seat.
And every time when the line it comes in the next day,
I'm not in the boat and he is.
And had gotten close to Michiel
over the last couple of years,
but I was afraid to ask him, but I called on a favor.
I went into his office. I said, I'm frustrated.
I deserve to be in that top boat, I'm faster.
The team knows on faster, the year round guys all think,
they say you should be in that boat, Jay.
And, but I'm not in it. I'm winning.
And I said, I just like to see if
I'm not asking for you to put me in,
I'm asking for you to watch a seat race.
And I remember him saying, he says, I'm busy. We'll see.
And it was, it wasn't really the response I was looking for.
So I was like okay, that made me not, then I felt bad,
but the next morning he's there.
And he comes to the morning workout.
He says, all right, I'm gonna be running seat racing.
And he says, so let's get out the boats.
Here's the lineups we're going.
So he's in the launch with the coach
who was coaching us that summer.
And we go out there and you never know
who's gonna get picked, but my name gets called.
We row, we get switched. I win.
And he just pulls the, his little bull horn out,
says from now on Jason's in the top boat, he won it.
And I was probably one of the best days of my rowing career.
And I went back to him and I just said, I appreciate that.
That you took the time.
He said, I knew I was gonna do it, but I couldn't tell you,
cause I didn't wanna give you
an advantage over your teammate
when you knew you were gonna seat race that day.
And he said, you deserved it.
And and I was able to make it there.
But that was largely because the team that I had spent
the last two years with day in and day out had,
I'd grown to love, they'd grown to love me.
And there was, there was a palpable feeling
when I got moved into the boat
and those guys look behind me, let's go J right now.
So then how far do you end up taking this?
I take it,
Win, a couple of gold medals in nationals,
a silver and a bronze, these kinds of things doing well,
but didn't qualify
for Beijing Olympic trials for 2008.
I mean, some guys did on our team.
And I just, wasn't one of those guys.
How does the selection process work
for the Olympics and rowing?
There's two ways to get selected in rowing.
One is to make the national team.
There's certain boats and the Olympics
where the national team coach simply selects the crew
that's gonna be in that boat.
So it's called the selection boat.
So you have to be on the national team.
And like the men's eight, for instance, is a selection boat,
or at least it was when I was there. I still think it is.
In which case the national team coach will say, all right,
these are the guys that are going to the Olympics.
Yeah. That's gotta be controversial.
Because that's highly subjective. Right?
I think a lot of people wish that they were,
it was all the other way,
which is what's called the trials boat.
So the rest of the, the other boats
that aren't selection boats are trials.
It's an, it's like the U.S. open. Anybody can enter.
You go to the open trials and you race.
And if your team wins, your crew wins, you go.
And at that point, I was in my best chance was,
was in a mens double.
So myself and my teammate, Mike Ross.
And we rode all pretty much all summer together
to try to try to, to try to be able to qualify.
But we, we didn't qualify.
We were, it was gonna be a long shot at best anyway for us.
Mike's a very good rower,
came from Marietta, very good rowing school,
incredibly gifted rower.
But, and we were, we were so hot, hot and cold all the time.
Sometimes we'd win a race, by a landslide,
and other times we wouldn't even get out of the heats so.
We just weren't able to qualify.
And it's still like, to this day, I just,
I think I just didn't have enough time, I'm still,
this is my third year of rowing at this point.
I mean, some people I had the last Olympics, I wasn't,
didn't even know what rowing was
when people were in the last Olympics so.
Right, so you get that far,
but are you thinking, all right,
I'm in it for the next four years for 2012 or,
you're gonna stick it out for that,
or how does that play out?
Yeah, that was the crossroads.
And I'm, trying to make that decision
and it's just, I put so much into it
and not that I expected to go.
I didn't, I was a long shot the entire time.
Like it just, I was small.
I was inexperienced compared to these guys,
but the thought of being another four years,
training and Philly putting off my career,
it was just, it seemed too much.
And so I'm not, not sure if like 100%
I made the right decision, but my decision was to be done.
So I retired.
Right so with that,
it kind of goes back to how I opened this,
which is you're this guy who has a lot of athletic talent,
you've got a lot of drive, you've demonstrated,
extreme potential you've had some success
but there's this sense of unfinished business, right?
Like, so you can go become a civilian,
but you're walking around sort of like a ticking time bomb
because there's this thing inside of you
that is yearning to come out.
Yeah. And it's just, I move back to California,
and that's what it is.
It's a restlessness begins to kind of set in.
And this permanent restlessness is just a hard thing
to cope with.
And I remember I'm not home for more than, I don't know,
four or five months then I decide to go travel.
So I leave on pretty much traveling off and on
for another year,
going to Europe and all these other places.
And, I just, I'm trying to find that thing.
And in the end, it was,
I was trying to just settle down permanently,
but I think it was just an intermission.
Was there an aware, like,
what is the relationship between
like the hardcore national team, Olympic caliber rowers,
and this whole other culture of ocean rowing.
Cause those, yes.
One's gonna feed the other, but they don't really intersect.
I mean, they're very different disciplines, right.
So is it looked down upon, is it revered?
Like, how does that interplay
between those two cultures work?
Well, I think they're actually just now starting to
blend in more with open ocean rowing
coming into the Olympics and becoming more
of an international sport.
So before--
Is open, open ocean rowing in the Olympics?
Its going to become an Olympic sport,
not trans ocean rowing,
but open ocean rowing where you're going distances
in open ocean.
And that's exciting for the sport.
And that is now starting, you're starting to see a blend.
So you now you're starting to see flat water rowers
or sprint rowers, collegiate and elite level rowers
start to think about transitioning in to open ocean.
When I started open ocean rowing, there, there was,
there was really no, we were the overlap.
But that was the big idea, right?
Like here, I'm gonna take everything I know
about athleticism and apply it to this world
that needs, an upgrade, like we're gonna approach this
from an elite athlete perspective,
versus like a salty sea where the, rogue kind of,
veteran ocean row guy perspective.
Exactly.
And so I would say at the time that I was starting
to do ocean rowing and doing exactly what you said,
I would say that each of the different practices
look down on the other one.
So I think flat water rowers the,
the world that I was coming from said,
no that's where you go when you don't make it.
Or like, you're not, you're,
you're just gonna use the one skill that you have,
which is endurance to try to win,
but you're not gonna be able to put the skill into it.
While the open ocean rowers said the opposite.
They said, where did rowing come from?
Well, it came from open ocean.
I mean, where did the first rowers where the Vikings.
These are the, this, everyone thinks of
traditional rowing as flat water on
that we see in the Olympics.
That's not what it was, what it was,
was big boats, rowing just great distances in the ocean.
And then it was people ferrying--
Its viking shit.
Yeah, exactly.
So the.
That's cute that you go,
to the Henley and like we're on that flat water,
for like a couple of minutes.
Yeah, exact.
But when you really want to understand what rowing is
like, come on over here.
That's exactly what it was.
And you'll, we'll see what you really are made of.
So I'm all of a sudden,
I've got my foot in both camps and I'm not being...
But you had to hurt, you had to sort of learn
the hard way.
Yeah. I mean--
the ultimate truth
where these, these salty dogs were coming from.
Exactly, and so where they were spending
a majority of their time saying look,
these salty sailors, they knew how to read the ocean
and weather patterns and they understood tides
and they understood weather.
They understood that world.
They spent those two years of training teaching themselves
to be better rowers.
Whereas this first row for us,
we were these kind of elite level rowers.
that had to teach themselves what it was like
to be on an open ocean.
How do you navigate?
How do you do that in the middle of the night?
Exactly. So you're dealing with--
And under appreciating how crucial that was
to the success of the entire affair.
Exactly, so when you've never done open ocean before
you're thinking, okay, I wrote for two hours,
which I can do that.
I've done that on the rowing machine plenty of times.
And then I rest for two hours and that's nice.
I remember, I'll tell you how naive I was.
I brought, I'm a pretty avid reader
and I brought like seven books with me.
I thought I was gonna be able to read on my off time.
I was like, this will be great.
I'll row hard. And then I'll just be in the cabin reading.
Well, I didn't get one sentence in, because first of all,
the first week you can't,
can't look at a book you're so seasick, your gonna throw up.
I was like,
this is the last thing you have time for us to read.
This is how naive I was.
And I still have those books on my shelf.
And I love looking at them,
they make me laugh because you got these nice books
with these great bindings.
And then you can see these ones that have just been
(indistinct conversation)
so they're all wrinkled up and stuff like that.
I didn't read them there
I read them when I got home.
That's hilarious, man.
Yeah and also on top of that, on top of the navigation,
it's like picking your route, like what's your line.
Yeah.
You're not gonna go straight line. First of all.
So there's two things with routing
that you're gonna have to deal with.
One is the overall route, the 3000 mile crossing
You can't go by way the Crow flies.
Cause you're gonna have to follow,
you wanna follow the currents and the tides
and when you get out and then the wind,
the prevailing winds,
so that doesn't often mean straight line usually means
some kind of a J shape.
And then the other thing is when you're out there,
you're making constantly making changes to your route
because you're, avoiding storms.
You have to go through storms, you have to go north foam,
south foam and you're not a, sailboat or a motorboat,
that's going 15, 20 knots your a,
if you're lucky going three to four knots,
so you're not gonna be able to avoid storms.
You're just going to try to get yourself in a position
to not be in them for very long.
So you're having to make all these routing decisions
and they don't have, we took classes on routing
basic routing, like how to read,
your GPS and how to like use the tools and instruments
on your boat to your advantage.
But the only, the only real way to learn
is to be out there doing it.
Yeah, there's no substitute for experience with that.
Right, like being in the ocean
and just having that tactile feel for like,
what's the right thing to do.
Exactly.
And that's kinda like where I feel like Angus is,
is like the dude when it comes to this.
Yeah. I mean to this day,
he's I would say some people get mad at me this,
I say he is the, the greatest ocean rower out there today
in the world. I mean, he is, he has proven.
Right so you, in your first Atlantic crossing,
you saw what he was capable of
and went like you just you're like,
I need that guy on my team now.
They, his team, his boat, British boat wins that year.
Right? Do they set the record?
No, they win the year.
They won the race that year.
So this is 2015/16, the same time Tom and I are out there.
They, they win the race. They set the course record,
but fall short of the world record by a day or so.
How is there a difference between
the course record and the world record?
Cause you don't have to enter this particular,
Atlantic campaigns is the race and it's,
it's a fantastic race, well organized.
They do a fantastic job.
But there's a lot of teams that don't wanna do the race.
They don't want--
They just do it on their own.
They push off.
In fact before Atlantic campaigns became
the organized event that it is today,
that's how people were doing it.
They were just going on their own.
Right. How long has that event been around?
It's been around for a while.
I think it, it was taken over by its current ownership.
I wanna say like 10 years ago,
by this gentlemen named Carsten,
great guy did a such a fantastic
he's done so much for the sport and organizing it this.
But I think this race has been going on since like 96.
So, you got the course record,
but then you've got the world record
and the world record was at that point set by a team
that went independent.
Cause what they're doing is they're gonna wait
for that perfect set to come in
and then they're gonna push off.
They're, they're not--
They go when the weather is right.
Not when the gun goes off.
And exactly.
And the race for safety sake requires certain things
which adds weight to the boat.
A life raft which is essentially
the weight of another human being.
60 days worth of food for five people. That's a lot of food.
If you're not, if you're not expecting to be,
if you wanna try and bring the world records,
you don't think you're gonna be out there for 60 days.
But you have to carry that weight.
You wanna be out there for half that,
so you cut, you're carrying double the food
that you're probably gonna need.
Yeah or even more because that's, were representing
5,000 calories per person per day.
And for the first week, you're not consuming that much
cause your sea sick.
Your sick.
And no matter what you're getting seasick,
everyone's getting seasick.
Is there something that comes with experience
where you get less seasick or you're able to dodge that?
I think, yeah.
I think with experience, you'll,
you'll know how to handle it better
and you'll know what your body needs to do to kind of,
to kind of eliminate some of the symptoms.
The worst is gonna be the first time you do it.
And it's just going to get,
you're going to take it on the chin.
For me I, fortunately for me I don't,
I don't actually physically get ill.
I'm very lucky,
but I mean the first five days I'm disoriented,
I'm dizzy and I have no appetite,
but one of the things I do is I like to starve it out.
So that sounds weird but like,
I will try to eat as little as possible.
I'll have a lot of calories going into the thing,
but like then I'll just, eating dry food,
a lot of dry stuff just
to keep the stomach feeling all right.
Until it just clears and then I'll be, I'll be starving.
Yeah. That seems dangerous though.
You could get yourself into a crazy deficit.
And my teammates have talked to me about that
and that's why I lose so much more weight than most of them,
but I like I can play in that space pretty well.
I know myself and I know I'm still,
my energy levels there and I can,
I've trained my body to burn that kind of slow burning
lean muscle mass for a long time, instead of,
just that, so the fat goes quick,
but then it's the lean muscle mass so.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book
"Voicing Change".
Featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in all wrapped
in a hardcover coffee table form that provides
a great taste of what we do here at the RRP
and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc, that's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
All right, let get back into it.
So you go back to this race and you put together
a whole different team. We talked about Angus.
But learning what you learned from the experience
of the year prior,
walk me through kind of the process
of wrapping your head around,
who are gonna be not necessarily the best people,
but the right people.
So you have that perfect recipe of
experience and athleticism, but also this,
kind of unified organism that we were talking about.
Yeah so, I know I'm doing it again
talk to my sponsors, they're in, they're excited.
And, but I'm kind of left with like this blank canvas.
I'm like sitting at my desk literally one day
just being like, okay, where do I start?
I want people like Tom, Tom's not in.
He's going to be the land manager for it,
but he'd done everything he needed to do.
So I want the people like Tom,
but where am I gonna get those guys?
And how am I gonna know?
Because I thought I had more people like that
on the first boat.
And to bring Angus up again,
Angus and I had become relatively close
over the course of the last year,
because although we were competitors,
he worked for the boat manufacturer
that we bought our boat from.
And just as two captains of two teams,
we talked and got to know each other at the start line
cause you're there for two weeks and he calls me one day.
This is kind of, as I'm kinda just sitting at my desk,
and he calls me one day and says,
I hear you're putting together a new team.
I said, yeah,
I am, I'm gonna do it again.
And I had heard that he was gonna do it.
And he said, yeah, cause some,
some team was going to pay him like 30,000 pounds
to like just literally skipper them across,
just and have that experience. They didn't have to learn it.
I said, congrats.
I told him, I said, congrats because,
that's, you don't make money in ocean rowing.
So for you to be able to make that, it's like fantastic.
And he says, well, if I, if,
if you haven't built your team
I would be interested in rowing with you, which shocked me.
I mean, I would love to have him on the team
for all the reasons we've already talked about,
but I don't have that kind of cash.
I'm like I don't have that money to pay him.
So I said, I don't, have any money to pay you.
And he said, well,
I'd be interested in just doing it for nothing.
And, I kind of balked and asked well
if you've got somebody who's willing to do 30,000
like maybe you should take that.
And he says, uses this line that I'll never forget, he says
I'm more interested in making history
than I am in making money.
To which I even say it to this day I said
man, you must have had that on a post-it note
on your computer somewhere, something like that.
People don't come up with cool lines like that on the phone,
like this is...
But I knew at that moment, I think when he said that line,
that this was the start of another Tom, a right guy.
It was a bonus that he had the experience and that he,
that he, the athlete that he was, but here,
we're talking about we're at 50%
of the right team right now.
So we committed and started building from there.
From there he said,
if I was putting this team together,
I'd call a guy named, Alex Simpson.
And I kind of heard that name before.
And he said, yeah, we rode together in the Indian ocean
because they had done the Indian ocean before the Atlantic.
I said so why is he so special?
I said that he's like, oh, he just shuts up in rows.
I'm thinking and I said well,
you might want to give a little more credit than that
if you want him to be on this team.
But what you're basically saying is like,
this is a guy that,
you've got a lot of type a personalities,
you and I are gonna be splitting this kind of this
skipper burden, so to speak, this leadership burden.
this is a guy who really is process-oriented.
He takes, he takes the strategy,
the idea of the leadership that is not his own,
but it kind of absorbs it as if it was
and passes it down to the rest of the team.
So I gave him a call.
This is, this guy's 10 years younger than me.
And so I'm a little worried about his,
young maturity kind of thing.
But from that first phone call just wants to know
how are we gonna do in eight months
that the rest of the teams that we're going against
are taking two years to prepare for.
It was just process, process, process.
And I understood what Angus was saying at that moment.
Meanwhile, your in California.
And they're both in great Britain.
This is something that we're having to discuss.
How much time are we really gonna be able to spend together?
Yeah.
So I'm wanting to get another American,
if we got three guys here now,
we've got two of them are, in the UK.
And then I've got myself here in the U.S.
And so I'm really trying to,
having the same problem as the year before,
I'm trying to round out this team and being
very, very careful and a guy wrote a Vesper with Matt brown,
very intelligent guy on top of being
a great rower, rowed at Yale then rowed at Oxford.
So an intelligent guy, and by the way...
But also like a beast.
Yeah also, forgot to mention also
like a ginormous human being who can like
bend an oar when he's putting it in the water.
But I think the thing that really attracted me to him
was that, and it sounds weird,
he just lost at Olympic trials.
So here we are, in the summer he didn't qualify
he went for the men's single.
That's the toughest one, you're by yourself.
And that's why by way that's a,
a trials boat, anyone can enter that.
Rich you could enter it next year
and go and try to do the open mic and,
and you'll have to get out of the heats, but he,
he got all the way to the finals, but didn't qualify.
And I'm thinking to myself, this is it. He's lost right now.
He's rudderless, no pun intended.
He's trying to figure out like, what am I gonna do?
This has been my dream. And now it's over.
And he's probably at the same crossroads.
Do I go another four years?
But he's got a two-year-old at home.
He's married with a two year old.
I mean, so as like, this is what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna offer them this something else.
And that's what I did. I called him.
And as he said to me, he's like,
yeah, you didn't have to finish the sentence, I'm in.
And it wasn't an I'm in because I'm naive,
and I don't understand this stuff.
He had been me and my race the year before.
And this guy was no stranger to hard work
and no stranger to be an underdog.
I mean, he came from, from nothing,
and built himself up to having
a first rate education through working hard.
So that was our team.
And all of a sudden, now we've got a team.
Yeah and taking everything that you would learn
the year prior and these kinds of lessons about
teamwork and leadership and what went wrong before
and how to course correct that.
Like how do you then approach,
this group of guys as a leader to get their heads around
what you guys are going to try to tackle
also while you're all dispersed all over the place.
Yeah, that was the, that was the big like,
that was the big problem to solve for.
And we've got very little time and I just,
I'm always hearkened back to this idea
that Tom and I had like, how do I recreate that,
like feeling that we had during those moments of breakfast
without actually saying, okay guys,
we're gonna do this breakfast thing.
Cause you can't, it has to be organic.
And I'm just realizing that,
as nice as it was to have one other guy
that you were kind of leveraging as human emotion,
he in turn was doing that to you.
Like, wouldn't it be nice if it was for the whole boat?
And then I like, I really didn't stop there.
I was thinking like, well,
we should include our family members.
like our wives and girlfriends and
our extended family and our friends and our neighbors.
I was like, if we created a community of people
that once we got to the boat and we started rowing,
we felt we're relying on us,
then that would be a strong motivator and then.
And so that's what I did.
I just basically started to create a community.
So we rowed and we got bigger and stronger
and we rowed together, but I, we went out there,
they came out our way and we just spent a lot of time
together as a team.
And it was, it was rowing, but it was also dinners.
It was drinks.
It was meeting each other's wives and girlfriends
and spending time with them.
It was, it was, it was brotherhood.
It was fraternity at that point, building this community,
this sense of community.
And then it was, if anybody in our family group,
our friend group, our neighbors wanted a job on this team
they wanted to be part of this team
we'd find something for them to do.
Something that we needed done so that when they did it,
they felt they were part of the narrative.
So you go fast forward to we're at the start line with,
or back at La Gomera, the start line a year later.
And there's, it feels different.
It feels like there is a lot more riding on this.
And when I go back to that thing,
where glory gets you to the start line,
but shame gets you through the finish.
There was this idea of feeling that we,
we had a lot of people that were,
that were looking up to us to do this,
to finish the narrative that they were a part of.
And that was a strong motivator and something again,
that I was kind of learning in its entirety
for the first time that
you've got people that are not saying,
do this or else, but are saying that I'm part of this story,
I'm passing the baton to you now,
now it's up to you guys, finish this story,
finish the unfinished business.
The stakes were a lot higher. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's not just about you in some kind of vainglorious thing.
You've got a lot of people invested in this,
but for the right reasons.
I'm sure everybody has their distinct respective why,
your job as a leader is to figure out
how to take all of those whys and,
and have them cohere to one kind of singular why
that will unite your yourself as a team
so that when you meet those obstacles,
which are a certainty and are gonna come in many
unpredictable ways that you'll be able to tap into
a different gear,
Exactly.
To support each other through it.
Yeah, I think that one of the many leadership burdens
that you have as a captain is that you need to take
everyone's individual-wise and somehow convince them
that by going through with the team why
that they will still be able to achieve
their individual wHYs. And that's tough thing to do.
Look, Matt was doing it for a certain reason.
Alex was doing it for another reason, Angus and myself,
we all had different reasons why we were there.
But what I try to convince them all is that to go
as fast as we can for as long as we can to go as hard
to give everything that we have out on that water,
will simultaneously take care of all of our other
singular agenda objectives.
And I think that's where that trust piece comes in
as a leader, is that people have to trust that
their individual objectives are gonna be taken care of
if they buy into the team objective.
That is a difficult thing to convince people.
Yeah, I would think so.
And even probably more difficult in a corporate context.
I mean, it's, the principles are the same, right?
Whether you're rowing a boat or you're leading a team
at some corporation as the leader,
you have to get everybody to,
to buy into some kind of singular vision.
And you're asking these people to give of themselves.
So what is their why for doing that?
And why should they trust you?
And when things get difficult, how are they gonna,
kind of stick with you and not just bail
and go get a job somewhere else.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think in a lot of times, and as part of my job,
I work with these corporations and teach this leadership.
And one of the things that they say is is that your,
your stories are great and your examples are great,
but like, I'm not rowing across an ocean
I'm just, I'm just doing this one single thing.
I think when you're in a corporation,
these corporate leaders,
their burden is to enoble, or like to make noble,
the effort that they are putting forth.
And when you're asking, and this is something that I'm,
this is something I'm quite passionate about is that
if you're asking someone to give all of themselves
to something, then you are also asking them
to be changed by that something.
I mean, that's what happens.
That's what happened with Tom and I,
and this is what I'm understanding is
we're in that second row is Tom and I are different people.
We're not the same people that left the shores
of La Gomera at the start line,
which is different because we gave all of ourselves to
this endeavor and to each other, we're just different now.
And we talk about it all the time.
And I'm also different
than I was before I left for that second row,
because I gave all myself.
And so did the team, we're all just different people now.
But that's not a casual thing to be asking someone to do
because there's a lot of people out there that say look,
I just wanna come into work every day and do
a really good job and then leave and then forget about it
and then come back and do the same thing the next day.
And that's fine, by the way, like that's absolutely fine.
But like, if you're a part of a,
if you're trying to like create, like you said,
like this idea of high-performance and yeah,
there's a lot of parallels between it.
Then that's what you're asking people to do.
You're asking people to actually be changed by,
I mean that's why I love change. That's right.
We give ourselves all of ourselves to somebody
and now we're different people because of it, we're in love.
And you must first be able to answer that for yourself.
And be okay with that with yourself.
Am I okay with being changed by the thing we're about to do?
Am I okay with being a different person when I come home.
Then once you've done that,
you need to be able to do that with everybody else.
People are gonna resist that.
Yeah. People are messy.
People are messy.
And that differentiator between just,
showing up and going through a certain routine
versus the high performance version of that
really boils down to that emotional piece,
understanding what motivates people,
how they tick, finding a way to tap into that
and engender that level of trust,
and then doing that kind of unromantic community building,
right?
Like that's, and that's what you did that second time
building that team.
Like, how do we, how do we create a community
that is gonna be self-supporting in all the best ways
while you have to put in the time,
you have to invest the energy into doing that.
Yeah. And that's the, like you said,
that's the non-sexy stuff that would, that the day to day.
99% of all this stuff is not, great.
I mean, think about the row.
Like the start is great.
Cause everyone's taking pictures, you're pushing off--
Why can't everyone just be wherever they live,
train really hard show up and we'll just crush this.
Yeah, exactly. That make my life a lot easier.
Yeah right.
Still trying to figure out what that is,
but that's what you got.
I mean, the start is great and the finish is great
and the middle is brutal and ruthless and uncomfortable,
and you wanna quit,
and you're getting into arguments with your teammates,
and stress levels high, and danger is high.
And you're rowing a million and a half strokes give or take.
I mean, there's a lot of mundaness in that,
not unlike the corporate world where you're saying,
oh, this is all great,
but every day I just do this stuff.
Like what if what, if I'm in procurement,
why does my job matter to larger organization?
The larger picture.
The leader needs to prove that it does prove that it does.
That consistency piece.
My favorite part of the documentary is,
when you guys are pushing off for this second Atlantic row.
And, it's Matt, right?
He just, he just hits it hard.
Like he's just going for it.
Like in that first couple hours, you're like, bro,
we're gonna be out here for like, a month.
Oh man.
Chill out.
But it's that competitive? Like that's what he knows.
He's yeah, no experience.
And he was the guy who didn't have the ocean experience
to realize like, hey man, you gotta like take it breezy.
Yeah. He was taking it like a 2000 unit.
And he just face-planted for like a week.
And I'm having deja vu with Nick the year before.
I mean, he goes in there, he goes in so hard and as he says,
I was highly motivated. I'm like yeah, I know you were.
Yeah. But you can't sustain--
In the most unsustainable way.
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, we're out here for over a month and he's going out.
I mean, he's drenched in sweat in the first three hours.
I mean, he's eating this like pasta dish that just I'm,
I'm sitting here going, I eating a dry granola bar.
I'm just, I'm waiting for it to hit me
because the seasickness is gonna hit.
And it hits him and man, it knocks him flat on the ground
and he is out five or six days.
And I'm in, I'm having deja vu from Nick
because he's doing the exact same thing.
He's in the cabin and I'll never forget,
we're taking shifts off of him.
And this is where,
I've got a chance to change the narrative here.
And I just, I just remember we,
we took shifts from him and, we kept going in there and,
he was just lying face down.
And I remember we had taken shifts I was like,
I got to at least see if you can row.
And I'll just never forget. He just looks up.
And I said, can you do it?
And he just looks up and says, we'll see.
And it was just like, I mean, this is,
this is a guy who gets into UCLA on academic merit,
finds out. He can row gets, gets recruited by Yale
after his first year then goes to Oxford
as if it's not good enough for him.
I mean, this guy just is--
And it sounds like he came from kind of
a messed up childhood, right?
Like it was a pretty rough situation.
He had a rough situation, that's his story, not mine,
but he, he had it bad and he,
he is, as he says,
I looked at teammates as obstacles that I had to crush.
And I always just thought that was such
an interesting way of looking at,
that's his whole life was that the people that I was with
were really just in my way and even teammates
were obstacles to him.
Right, so no wonder he ends up
as a single skull rower right.
But that doesn't work when you got four guys
who have to live with each other for a month plus
in the open sea.
But I think I, to this day I think,
maybe him getting sick was the best thing
that could have happened for him and the team
because he saw yep, exactly. And he saw what the team did.
We picked them up, seamlessly myself, Angus, Alex.
It wasn't a, just so you know,
we're rowing your hours right now. None of that.
And I mean, he fell asleep. He was delirious.
I mean he woke up and he didn't realize
how long he'd been out.
We got it, and by the way, stay in there. We got you still.
And I think this was, this was a game changer for him.
I mean, when he got better and he did and he got stronger,
but it took them a week plus,
he felt he had to live up to a makeup for it.
And he didn't of course,
because that's not what teams are about,
but he was so humbled and so appreciative
that he became, he became an animal out there.
I mean, it was insane.
And when we were chasing the world record
and it was coming down to the hour,
he was that differentiate.
I mean, he was rowing for six hours straight
without stopping.
It was insane.
Yeah. So you guys didn't have the most auspicious start,
but you kind of find your groove,
you get some good weather.
You're throwing it down pretty hard.
You got some storm, I mean,
there's all kinds of shit that happened.
Day 50, there's some crazy storm,
or day, what day was that? Day?
30, it was probably around day 30.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But then you just throw the hammer down in these final days
and you're just busting out like 80, 90 mile days to,
come in and eclipse the world record by pretty good margin.
Yeah. I mean,
without giving too much away with the doc and stuff,
but I think the pinnacle of my athletic career
came at that moment on day 30, we get knocked by this storm
that should be there, pushes us backwards.
We have to anchor for just a few hours.
But when, when you're talking about,
barely being ahead of the world's record, this matters,
and finally the storms kind of starting to pass.
We're able to pull up the pair anchor, start rowing again.
And at one point we were going 0.8 knots, 0.8 knots.
That is you can crawl on your hands and knees at about that.
How many days did that go on for?
It was only--
Ended you just ended up dropping anchor.
Yeah, basically it started the day before
on January 12th and it slowed us down,
slowed us down until finally January 13th,
which was Friday the 13th. I'm not superstitious until now.
Now I am, but it hit us hard.
And that's when it just slows down.
We had to, we couldn't make any forward progress.
So we had to drop the anchor.
So we wouldn't get pushed back.
We're only in anchor for a handful of hours,
but it's enough because not only are we not going anywhere,
but like we've been not going anywhere
for about a day and a half now.
So we start rowing I'm in the cabin
and I'm having to do the math, what has this storm like,
what are the repercussions of this storm?
What's it done to us?
It ends up being really, really simple math,
I'm checking it over and over because I got
you get this kind of mental fog when you're out there.
Cause you just have such little stimulation
plus you're sleep deprived and malnourished and dehydrated.
But it's really simple math. We've got basically,
almost exactly to the mile 400 miles left to go
and almost exactly to the hour, five days to do it.
So it becomes 80 mile days.
We have to basically achieve 80 miles a day
for the next five days.
And then like, it'll be close if we do that.
And just to put in perspective,
70 mile days is world record pace at that point,
like that was what would have done it.
So like I'm in the cabin, I'm just,
I'm upset and I'm starting to cry a little bit.
I'm just, this isn't fair. We've worked too hard.
These guys have worked too hard and,
kind of like compose myself a little
'cause I know they're waiting for me
to come out there with the,
with the number and I come out and
I've got these three expectant faces looking at me.
And I tell them what I tell them
and the responses were just so interesting.
I'll never forget.
First of all, Matt, who,
seasick and kind of comes back, roaring back, so to speak,
he goes, oh my God, thank God.
I thought you were gonna say a hundred.
Like this guy was genuinely relieved
that we only had to do 80 miles a day,
which is 10 miles above world record pace.
Like he believed so much that this team was capable of it,
that he was relieved that it was only 80.
And then Alex, the young kid process oriented guy,
he was just like, I'll do whatever it takes Skip.
He called me Skip all the time.
And said I'll like,
I'll row every hour of the night if I have to.
Meaning, and those were his worst nights,
he would literally pass out in the middle
of his rowing shift cause he'd be so tired,
just like blackout sometimes.
And all of a sudden I feel heavy and I look back
and he's like half the elbow.
I'm like, you've got to get up.
He was just letting us know that he would row
his worst hours if that's what it was taken.
Like he was all in.
And then Angus, he was just saying that this is what we did.
This is why we combined forces.
We want a chance at history.
It's not like a great one, but we've got one in it's hours.
And I thought, damn if that isn't the best response
of any three teammates you could ever have.
I mean, that was when I knew that,
like I had done what we needed to do.
I came back because I failed as a leader
with the first team.
And its more specifically with Greg,
the guy who left, who was healthy,
it's, I always say it's easy to get down on Greg
he left, he abandoned us and believe me,
you don't wanna say his name in front of my dad
because my dad can't stand him.
But in the end it was my fault.
I failed to get him to a place
that he wanted to be like Tom.
And I never could shake that.
And so that's why I came back and all of a sudden I've got
three guys that are willing to do whatever it takes.
And the next five days when they're, were already beat up,
I mean, we're so beat up.
And so I said, all right.
So we row the first of that five days
because we're not quite out of the storm.
We row three people at a time, instead of two it's three.
Which means instead of two hours on two hours off,
you've got two hours on 40 minutes of rest.
And I'm thinking to myself,
this is going to be a rough first day.
And we do it for 24 straight hours. And we row 79 miles,
which is good.
Good, but you're behind.
But yeah, for putting all that much effort into it
were still one mile off of our pace.
And I just think that I'm thinking to myself,
I remember just as kind of like we're starting the next
official day, which I think we marked at 6:00 AM.
Was that the next official day for us?
I just remember thinking, like, I don't know.
I could see people taking their foot off the gas
a little bit right now.
Cause we're gonna go back to two on two off,
we're gonna go back to our normal shift pattern.
So I'm thinking to myself,
If you couldn't get 80 with three dudes.
How are you gonna do it with two.
Maybe you'll just--
On less rest.
Yeah a little bit off their foot off the gas.
I mean, I'm thinking to myself,
I got to make sure I don't do that.
Because now you're, now feeling a little defeated,
like I don't think we've got it.
But I can tell you what I know for a fact that nobody did,
because on that second day we did 94 miles.
Which just that's all that you needed to know
is that we did 95 miles and the third was 92.
So like five knots. What is that like?
Yeah, it was, no, it wasn't,
it wasn't quite five, but it was like, yeah,
it was so four knots will get you a 100 roughly.
Okay.
And so we were,
we're like in the high threes all day long
making quick shift changes,
like everything was in the thing is
nobody was talking about the world record pace.
That's the thing is like,
no one was saying like, alright,
where are we on the world record pace.
Like, it just became about like each other,
it just became about cooking extra food for everybody.
Hey, what does everybody want?
I'm gonna cook five meals right now.
So that you've got some,
I'm going to put it right next to your seat. Boom, eat it.
I had this infected heel, thing hurts so bad.
It was, it was so infected like even just barely touching it
like really, really like kind of sent like a pain up my leg.
And I'm notorious for not taking care
of my body very well out there when I should.
And Angus always yells at me for that.
And he would do little self things like hey Jay,
when you get back in the cabin, I laid it out.
You don't have to do anything. The gauze is there.
The wrap is there.
All you need to do is just simply take off the thing,
clean it wrap it done.
And like, he would just, he was encouraging me to do
what I needed to do to take care of my body.
And that was what everybody was doing.
Nobody was talking about themselves.
Oh, I'm so tired guys. I'm so beat up.
It was all about how are you doing?
And that was to this day.
It's the pinnacle of my athletic career.
That, those five days. And I was, I honestly,
no one's gonna believe this, but I didn't care anymore
if we broke the world record, I didn't.
We did we ended up doing it.
But in that moment, I'm thinking to myself, this is it.
This is what, this is what I was trying so hard for it.
I chased this like idea of
the only time I'm gonna be accepted,
I'm gonna accept myself or I'm gonna be accepted
as an elite athlete, a winner is if, if it's a gold medal,
if it's a world record.
And you start to realize like no one gives a shit,
like it doesn't matter about that.
What it matters is about is that when you step off that boat
or when you cross that finish line, that you know that,
that you led the team in the right way and that you gave
everything that you had and they did as well,
because of all this stuff that we've been talking about.
Yeah, yeah. That's beautifully put.
So then with that experience in breaking the world record
and having this, extraordinary kind of camaraderie
with your teammates, like, what do you make of that.
Like how do you extrapolate upon that to,
communicate to the average person or somebody
who's striving to achieve a goal or somebody
who is a leader in their respective employment.
I have a lot of thoughts around that,
but I'll take it to its most basic level.
And I'll say it by this, like we hear this cliche
all the time that life is short, right?
We always life is short. Life is short.
I don't actually believe that life is short or at least
I don't think we actually believe it.
I mean, whether life is long or short,
I guess just depends on what you compare it to.
If you compare it to a giant Redwood, it's short,
but if you compare it to like a fly its long,
whatever it is, but what do we believe?
And I think most people to include myself at times,
we believe life is long.
It's actually so long in fact
that we put off these things, right.
We always wanted to take piano lessons,
but we'll do it next year when my life isn't as busy.
We do all these different things.
I'm gonna patch things up with my,
my mom or my dad. I haven't talked to in a while,
I'll do it next week. I'll make the call next week,
next month, whatever it is.
And we put things off because we honestly believe
we have more time.
And the reality is is that,
that is exactly what keeps us from doing these things,
is it, we always think we've got more time.
And so if I'm talking about, at the most basic level,
when we start to attempt these things,
we should honestly have a deep seated belief
that life is finite, it's short and it's fleeting.
And in which case we will start to act now.
I think if we're talking about,
when we're starting to talk about,
talk to the individual out there that's listening right now,
I'd say that we need to start by how we think about time
and how we think about how we spend our time.
Because as we all know, weeks become months become years.
And all of a sudden that's how we spend our lives.
And I think I'm, I'm afraid,
I'm fearful that I'm not gonna be able to get
these things done because I'm running out of time.
And that helps me.
And I think, I hope that helps other people as well.
Yeah, that's amazing.
Dude we haven't even talked about rowing the Pacific yet.
What time is it?
You're just a month out basically of doing
the craziest thing you've done to date.
So, so walk me through the process of,
of getting enthusiastic about this challenge,
this idea that perhaps even after setting this world record,
that you weren't done,
that there was this other challenge out there,
that you wanted to tackle and putting the team together.
Like the audience is gonna kill me
if I don't ask you like how you train for all this stuff.
So yeah walk me up to this, to this,
latest adventure and, everything that went into it.
Yeah. I mean, I feel like I've gotten all these
new tools and lessons you keep using the metaphor
that I'm basically getting a master's in leadership here.
And so that's why I feel like,
I feel like I just graduated after this Atlantic row
with a master's and now I wanna go apply it.
And that's really where the motivation
from the Pacific came.
Is I've seen this idea of leveraging each other's
human emotions to build this community,
to build all this trust,
all things we've been talking about it,
I've seen how it works.
And now I wanna just go ahead and leverage
the hell out of it,
because I think that this is going to be...
Like you find, the lights have gone on you finally got it.
And now you could actually return and execute
at the highest level, because you've got the skills,
the experience, the endurance you've met the obstacles.
all of it.
Yeah. And that's what, and that's where we're at.
So, I live in the San Francisco bay area.
The Pacific is my backyard.
And so what better thing to have,
to enter the race that leaves from your backyard
and goes to Hawaii.
So that's where the motivation comes from.
I'm excited to build a new team.
Why a new team though. Why not just get all these guys?
Yeah.
You got your guy.
But those guys are, their whys are changing.
People are living their lives. How dare they?
I thought that was selfish. I'm glad you think the same.
Well Matt, I've never seen anyone
have more closure than Matt.
Matt after this row and the doc does a great job of kind of,
of showing this, but Matt has so much closure
after this row, both athletically his athletic career,
but also his personal life.
This idea of being able to really kind of close the loop
on his, on a lot of the things.
He has no interest and believe me, I tried.
But he's done. He's like, Jay, I'm done.
I am done.
He learned what he needed to learn.
He's out.
He got that closure.
He had that experience and now he can cut the ties
and build a new life on top of that.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's exactly what he did.
They had another kid and they're living a happy life
in Texas right now.
So--
But Angus?
Well Angus, isn't going anywhere.
Holler at my boy. He's my dude.
Yeah. He's the best.
He's, this is his life and for him,
his motivation is different again,
this is for another time but,
he's more comfortable, he's a guy has always been
more comfortable out at sea than he was indoors.
I mean, I like to come home. I love these things.
But I also like to come home,
for me, it's I wanna see my wife, I wanna see my son,
I wanna spend time with friends and family
and go golfing and run my business
I want to do these things.
But Angus always seems like tough to reenter,
like he always has a hard time coming back and I think
he's, chasing something that would be his
that's for him to answer not me,
but he was ready. So he was in, so it was me and him.
And now we're looking for two other guys and,
one of his first teammates from the first time
in the Atlantic Gus Barton was in.
And he's a he's a personal trainer in London
and a great athlete and has experience.
And then Duncan Roy was our next guy
who had rowed the Atlantic twice already as well.
And his big motivation was that he didn't really feel like
he had the experience that he wanted to have
in both those rows for different reasons.
He was looking for an ultimate team experience.
And so we had this team, but COVID,
we're all sick of talking about COVID,
but it precluded us from doing it 2020,
which was when we were supposed to do it.
And so that comes and goes, and we now sit here.
We built ourselves up Gus has to,
has to bow out because his wife was planning on
growing they're growing their family and having a child.
Which I totally understand. So he can't be in for 2021.
So we're looking for this fourth guy.
And Duncan, we all put together a list of people
that we'd be interested in.
Duncan had a couple of guys on his list.
And one of those guys we ended up taking, which was,
which was Jordan Shuttleworth and again,
no experience on the ocean. So we're talking about--
You always give one guy who has no ocean experience.
We just wanna make sure that we make it
just a little bit harder for ourselves.
So yeah, he's a former Royal Marine,
big, strong athletic individual,
but no ocean rowing experience.
And so, here we are,
here's our team coming into this year,
myself, Angus, who are, who's at this point,
my brother in adventure at this,
we've done so much together.
And then Duncan, who I'd never rode with in a boat before
in terms of a race, but have now spent
a lot of time with and just absolutely loved.
And then Jordan.
Right so I'm less familiar with Duncan and Jordan
because they're not in the documentary.
Because the documentary ends before the Pacific row,
but both military guys, which is interesting.
Yeah.
But also I trust come from some kind of
competitive rowing background or just like ocean dudes.
Duncan was ocean rowing.
He'd done two ocean crossings already
and really has fallen in love with it.
And Jordan, no,
no like really no nautical background.
Right, he's just a bad-ass Marine commando
who's tough as nails.
And never rowed in the ocean.
And you're like, that's our guy.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Like I haven't learned my lesson.
Well, it's just, it was,
we interviewed quite a few people to include people
that had ocean rowing experience, but he just seemed,
he just, he had that.
I'll tell you what I loved about Jordan.
I mean, there's a lot of things I love about Jordan.
Of course, especially now that we finished one together,
we're like brothers, but the first thing he said,
when we got on our first interview with him,
Zoom of course, and he says, I'm nervous.
What are you, what are you nervous?
He's like, I just want this so bad.
I just thought that is a great, I liked that,
that he there's already so much on it for him.
And he, I asked him, I said,
do you remember the first thing you said?
And he couldn't remember.
And I just remember it came from the heart.
He was just, he looked nervous and I just loved that.
It meant something to him.
The interesting thing about Angus is,
I looked into his background a little bit,
in addition to being the youngest ever to row
the Indian Atlantic and Pacific,
the guy has dealt with depression and ADHD.
And some, he's got some dark chapters in his past
that he had to kind of face and overcome.
Yeah and this has been,
something that we've constantly talked about.
I mean, we rowed the Atlantic together,
broke the world record.
Then a year later, we trekked across Namibia together.
Something that we don't talk a lot about,
but that was an incredible vacation,
a vacation with adventure.
(indistinct conversation)
That was anything but.
He didn't actually complete that one because
he got heat stroke and passed out and hit his head.
And then after that, he went into a tough time.
And there was actually about a six month stint
where I couldn't get ahold of him.
Most of his friends couldn't get ahold of him
and I'm the U.S. and he's in the UK.
So I'd be calling him and Alex,
our team mate from the Atlantic actually was trying so hard
to get ahold of him and he wouldn't respond to any of us.
So Alex somehow had one of his old credit cards
started using it at the bars.
He's like, well, if he's not gonna answer my phone calls,
I'm just gonna start charging the hell out of this thing
until he calls me pissed off.
But we and as it turned out,
what we learned is that he was just, he had,
he was wrestling with a lot of tough thoughts
and he's struggled with depression.
He's now in a much better situation.
He's in a very healthy relationship with a wonderful woman.
And, but it's not gone, he still has to deal with it.
And so it's, again that's his story,
but it's something that,
we've, we have to constantly talk about because
that's going to affect the that's going to affect
us being out there.
Yeah. I saw a piece, I think it was Vice that you did,
or it was kind of like a mini doc and it was you guys like
getting ready for this race and it feels like in this case,
you guys were together more or were those
just training partners that live out near you?
These are my training partners.
I wish those are my teammates.
I mean glad that my buddies helped out, but I mean,
that's what happens is that, especially with COVID,
we got together, I met Jordan face to face
for the first time when he got to San Francisco.
Wow.
Those I've got San Francisco Bear. I got, I've got,
training buddies, Mike Voksichu,
I rowed with in college. He goes out in the water with me,
And I got Kevin Grant, who's a collegiate football player.
So I do the weights with him and I got swimming partners,
trail running partners.
So those guys helped me get in shape.
I've got my committee that's great,
but we didn't, have any time to train together.
So we, you get to San Francisco,
we got two weeks until this row starts here.
This is this past may. Boat's not ready.
And not nearly as ready as we'd like it to be.
We haven't even all really spent any time together.
COVID slowing everything down because even at this point,
we're still struggling with stuff and we're way,
way over budget and underfunded.
So I mean, this is the team that shows you--
So you as a guy who's taught at business schools
and has all this wisdom about teammate team building
and leadership, you're breaking all your rules.
It's, it's. Yeah.
And, again, we got to say,
I could sit here and give you a litany of excuses.
Hey, well, it was COVID this and COVID that.
And in the end, it comes down to me.
In the end, it is my fault.
So we're not ready. We're not prepared.
We didn't raise enough money for this thing.
We didn't get enough sponsorship.
Well, whatever, this is my,
I have this team and this boat and this race ahead of us.
And those two weeks were not ideal to be fair.
And as we led up to this row, and so May were, instead of,
I was going to take them to a Giants game and,
we were gonna go and do all these fun things,
take them to the city.
They wanted to see a cable car and all,
they didn't believe that it gets pulled by a cable.
So I was gonna do all this stuff.
We spent every single day, all day at the boat,
getting it ready until literally the night before.
And so here we are just like you said,
we'll have broken all the rules,
but, in that time was spent with each other
and it was stressful, but it was together.
And there was a ton of trust
and community building happening.
And I remember like the night before my wife asking me
how I was feeling, cause you know
it was a very stressful week, two weeks leading up.
And I said, I can't wait until tomorrow morning.
All I have to do is push off.
And I'll all this left is the suffering.
And that's how I felt like I,
I truly felt that we were still where we needed to be.
And all that was left is to just do it.
Michiel, just to bring it back to my,
my Vesper coach there three times olympian
he used to always say, medals are earned in the off season.
you simply just row the race to go pick them up.
And I love the simplicity of that.
Like simply just row the 2000 meters because the metals
are at the finish line. You've just got to go pick them up.
Whatever color you get is a result of what you did
in the off season. And that's how I felt with this team.
Like we had done the work, it was stressful,
but we were ready.
The boat was where it needs to be,
the team together where they need to be all,
we need to push off.
Yeah.
And we did.
Talk to me about the training.
So you would think, I thought, I guess I should say
that your training would be you on a boat in the bay
as much as possible then on a a CompuTrainer
and then you in the weight room,
but in that little mini doc that I watched,
you were doing all kinds of interesting different stuff.
A lot of cuddle ball work, a lot of like calisthenic type,
HIT type training where you're changing gears a lot,
trying to confuse the body.
So walk me through, the kind of philosophy and perspective
and routine that you were doing to get ready.
Yeah so ideally the number one thing you could do
to get yourself ready to be in your boat
with your team on the ocean rowing, every day.
As much as possible.
That's number one. Whenever you can do that, you do it.
Multi-day rows getting out there, sleeping on the boat,
rowing in different conditions that's the best,
but that just doesn't happen.
I mean, even on a non COVID year,
it's hard to get the team together, but when we can, we do.
Then you get down to rowing machine, So the ERG, I mean,
I'll sit on there and I do a lot of different training.
Sometimes it'll be long, long, steady state pieces on that,
where I'm just trying to keep my heart rate
and I do all heart rate training.
So it's really based on where the heart rate is
not where the split is.
Then we'll do an interval work and strength work
on the rowing machine.
And then from there, lifting is a big deal.
Rowing is a leg sport.
Mostly most people think it's an upper body.
It's not it's, you push off of a sliding seat.
You don't pull, pushing is most of it.
So you're building that legs,
you're building the core and of course the back
and shoulders as well.
So a lot of that, but then,
you can't be too singular and just real.
It's a lot of, a lot of pressure on the back.
So I do a lot of cross training.
And for me cross training is I like to do trail running
because I enjoy it and I'm not, and it's hard for me.
Cause I'm a big guy, and swimming,
swimming is become a huge part of my training now
because it's that nice fluid motion.
And I can, it's a lengthening thing for me.
So it makes my back feel good.
So I'm doing a combination of all that, but in a day to day,
I'm getting up at 4:30
if this is what people want to know,
I'm getting up at 4:30 before my son and my wife are up.
I'm doing a big row there. That's a, that's an ergo,
that's a rowing machine workout.
That'll be a two hour session
depending on what the day looks like.
And then I'm usually doing some kind of a mid day,
afternoon thing that'll be either
in the weight room or be some kind of like
park workout that will just bring a medicine balls
and stuff and we'll start to do stuff in the park
and that'll be kind of more of a muscular endurance
type of workout.
And then usually on certain days,
usually three days a week after I put my son to bed,
he's down at 7:30, then I'll go for a night run.
Just something light not pushing it,
nothing like you do Rich, but just getting out there,
and just trying to like break a sweat and make it feel,
make it feel good.
And then that's, so I'm doing two days,
Monday through Saturday,
and then two or three of those days,
I'll put in a light run as well in the evenings.
And then Sunday I'll usually take off.
Right so what I didn't hear is you
getting out on the water?
Well, usually we get two, but this time the Pacific,
there was almost no water time.
First of all, our boat wasn't ready.
Even getting out in a skull.
Yeah and I did, I did a lot of that as well, but
it's tough, you know, it's tough with, with a family.
Yeah. It's time consuming
(indistinct conversation)
So it's like, do I do that
or do I get on the rowing machine, which is in my garage.
And I got a little set up there and I can just get there
And you have the background and the experience like, yeah.
I wasn't as worried about the,
for me as the rowing portion of it,
in terms of the feel of the oars,
that I've spent a lot of my adult hood
dealing within training for.
So it was for me, it's just about
sitting and getting bigger and stronger and fitter.
Packing on the weight.
Putting on the muscle mass,
because that's gonna get eroded over time
and kind of becomes a fuel.
Yeah.
I mean, what happens is you start, you start high,
the adrenaline then you crash with the seasickness.
And then after you get all the sea sickness,
you come back up and you're probably at your highest point.
At that point, you feel the best,
maybe five days into the row.
And then it's a slow descent, slow and steady descent,
as you lose the fat, which goes away quick, then start,
you start burning into that muscle mass.
And you start feeling those injuries.
You get the stress fractured ribs,
you've got sores on your ass.
You've got your hands on--
How do you get on top of those sores.
Cause that's just nuts.
And all they're just being exposed to.
They're just wet all the time, salt, everything.
Its awful. I'm gonna be honest, it is the worst.
So for that, you hear that old proverb that says
it's not the mountain in front of you,
but the pebble in your shoe, that's what ocean rowing is.
It's not the distance that you're rowing that's so hard.
It's the little things.
And that's getting ahead of it real quick.
So, yeah the minute you get started getting wet,
you get hit by a wave.
I mean, you might not be dry for another two days
from that one single way that hits you.
You're soaking wet and then it gets down to your butt
and so the salt is just grinding into your butt.
And then you get the sores.
And it's a combination of trying to drive them out,
but also keeping them so that they,
keeping them also like with some,
some lubricant basically so that they don't get worse.
So it's this fine balance between drying them out.
You're on a 30 foot boat. Where are you drying?
There's no, we don't have a bathroom on it.
Did you just have vats of anti-microbial
like Neosporin type shit that you rub on your ass
and on your feet all the time.
You got your phone trying to take a selfie
to see where it is or just asking one of your buddies,
dude, I need you to look at my ass.
Its like oh God.
And I saw the Instagram like sleeping naked.
Cause you got to, you're trying to dry it out.
Yeah you just see it just, I mean,
there's no shame on this boat.
I mean, you can use your imagination, but I mean,
you're asking guys to look at things
that you can't see on your body.
I need you to check this thing out,
and then, or a guy will see you, like, take down,
drop down your shorts back, dude, your ass looks awful.
You got to fix that.
I mean just as a cyclist like I can't imagine
the saddle sore situation.
Yeah. It's for me, it's one of the worst things.
So I had that, and like I had a bad ankle issue on this one
that just, and it's just those little things
that you're just trying to figure out.
You've got two hours to somehow make it better
before you go out for another two hours and make it worse.
So it's just this,
this idea of like trying to figure that out.
And then of course you're tired.
All you really want to do is just lie down and go to sleep.
But you've got to stay up and fix those things.
And that can be that's when of those two hours
of not rowing is tough.
So yeah, you've got stress fractured ribs.
You've got salt sores on your ass.
You've got tendonitis where your hands
don't even straighten out and your,
you got numbness in your hands.
You've got, blisters,
obviously that hopefully will callus up.
And then, you're just getting,
you get headaches, you get dizziness.
It's just, it's brutal out there.
And how much clean water
can the desalinater produce daily.
It really depends on how much sunlight you're getting
because you're, everything's being powered by solar panels.
And how much you've had to use for other things.
But we--
Keep those phones charged. Get those videos.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. You got an auto, an auto helmet.
that's helping you keep your,
your point and stuff like that. Your bearing.
Is solar creating the energy for your navigation,
for it's everything.
Everything, everything that's right. Yeah.
It's all, it's all being lithium ion batteries on this race,
which is the first time we did, which ended up being great.
But I would,
I like having five liters of water per 24 hours
for each individual is good. That's nice.
And think about, it's not that much water.
That's not that much.
Plus you're using it also to make your food.
You can't like use that for taking a shower.
(indistinct conversation)
It's it's, that's the precious resource.
And a couple of times I think we did
three times on this last race
you need to wash the bottom of the boat,
actually if you can believe it,
barnacles build up on the bottom of the boat. Right.
You get a slime that gets there and then
the barnacles stick to the slime.
There's another interesting thing.
You're in the middle of the ocean.
You jump in and you just,
you're swimming in the middle of the ocean.
It's an incredible experience that I always encourage
all my teammates if they haven't done it before it,
some don't want it like, hell no, I'm not going in here.
But I always encourage you if you're not too scared
to do it. And most people take you up on it.
It's just an incredible feeling like, tethered to the boat.
But like you're just away from the boat.
You're, and it's obviously gonna be in calm weather,
you not gonna do it during a storm
and just to go under water naked and it feels so good.
Yeah. So you're getting that kind of,
that's your closest thing to a shower, just to--
I mean that's a religious experience.
Its is an unbelievably religious.
It is so true.
I mean, it is one of the most amazing things
to know you have 30,000 feet below you.
I love to just, I do it every time.
I just like push off and just swim down
and then just like do a 360 under water.
And just as far as the eye can see
and the lights being funneled, because it's so deep
and you can just see it being squished in. It's amazing.
I mean as an adventure athlete as an explorer,
there's this, I mean, perhaps you're the only human being
that's ever been in that spot
ever in the history of humanity.
Yeah. I think that all the time.
I think it's crazy.
That's what, we're all.
that's what adventures are trying to do.
Has, anyone other humans,
foot ever been where I'm standing on this Terrafirma.
And that's what we think about out there is you just
for a second, just have your own experience.
Just the guys are joking around, and everyone's,
and some guys are working on scrubbing the boat
and stuff like that.
And you can just have this one moment
to yourself you're like,
and I always think like I'm exactly where
I need to be right now and that is again,
if we're gonna wrap this whole thing up,
this is why we're doing it.
I mean, we're doing things like this to satiate this
very human need to push further,
to be somewhere that no one else has been to,
to get away and to be present.
And there is nothing more to feel to make you feel
present than something like that experience.
Yeah. Yeah.
So you get it done. You not only break the world record,
you like demolish it by nine days basically,
from 39 days to 30 days.
Yeah. It's insane.
So the thing that you always were waiting for
this guy who was, kind of in the shadows
always second place never could quite, execute on the dream,
I mean that's gotta be pretty gratifying.
Yeah it's, I'm,
I'm on the path to where I wanna be doing it
the way that I wanna do it.
And, but I'm not done, and I think right now it's about,
as I said before, taking this relatively new knowledge
this this master's degree, which I'm gonna use by the way,
because this is amazing. This is a great metaphor.
Yeah but you're teetering into PhD territory,
but there's a dissertation involved.
So maybe that's what you're thinking about
in terms of what's next.
And I think, I just love to see these tools
going into action and them actually working,
it's just an amazing thing to see all this work
that we've done and you just see,
you create an environment for these human beings
to be amazing and then they are, and you just,
you sit there and you Marvel at it because
in the end, what I'm doing is I'm not proving to the world
that I'm just some great athlete, I'm as great as I can be,
but I'm proving to the world that I'm a builder of teams.
And that is why you'll no matter what you see me do next,
it'll be in a team atmosphere.
Do you have a sense of what might be coming next?
I definitely have a short list.
Get all cagey on me now.
(indistinct conversation)
Its just you and me.
That's right.
No one listens to your podcast. I forgot about that.
Also. I'll just say this, I'll say this
I think I'm largely done with oceans.
I think I've, I don't think
there's anything left for me out there.
I mean I would do, I would do some more interesting,
maybe shorter crossings, but I think trans Atlantic
trans Pacific ocean crossing is I'm done with that,
but I've been looking to other bodies of water, big rivers,
the world's biggest rivers and doing some of those
and being able to do some more,
exploring some more adventuring where yeah,
there's still a record to be had, a source to see type of
crop, going down rivers and stuff,
but also being able to explore Tara from at times
being able to come on to land,
just seeing a little bit more
of the world through the rivers.
I'm not saying more than that for now.
No, I get it.
I mean, I'm interested in kind of
how your recent experience has,
or has not maybe impacted how you think about your why
for yourself as an adventure athlete who now has,
made the stamp, established yourself as somebody
who can do amazing things who is in a position
to garner additional support and, attention, et cetera.
And I think of people,
in the tradition of this like Lewis Pugh,
who's like about to jump in freezing cold water
and, swim across these frigid,
Icelandic or where is he's in Greenland? I'm sorry.
Swimming in swimming in the coldest water there is.
But his why is tied to a cause greater than himself.
I mean, you're about team building and leadership
and community building, et cetera.
Not that that's not completely laudable,
but his thing being like, the environment and all of that.
So I'm interested in kind of
has your perspective on what you,
like the sort of larger why behind what you're doing
is that, in flux, are you locked in on that?
Or how do you think about that?
As very inelegantly said.
I know, I think about this stuff so much
while you were talking so elegantly, by the way,
I was also trying to think about how,
how I kind of wrestle with that idea.
And I'd say the first thing is,
is that some of this is set in stone and it's becoming
more and more stronger within me and my why.
And that's a lot of the personal why.
Things like doing this for my son.
He'll be two in a week and,
he doesn't know what I do yet and he's only two,
but he will start to in the next few years,
start to slowly realized that his dad has done some,
some incredible things.
And, I might sound a little cheesy,
but for those parents out there, you know that,
that your why becomes pretty strong for your kids.
And it's for him to be able to see that his dad
does these things.
So whatever he gets into that, he's gonna know that,
he's got a chance, he's got a shot and that's just,
I'm so excited to be able to use that
as kind of a leverage for him as well.
And, I'm excited I...
That, this was my first row I've ever done my first
adventure with him alive.
That was tough, but also a motivator.
I put him to bed the night before I left
and he woke up the next day and I wasn't there.
And then I wasn't there for the next 30 days.
Does that change your kind of risk analysis approach?
I thought it would but it didn't.
And to be very honest and that sounds selfish
and it is, but I didn't, I didn't feel myself feeling
any more mortal out there than I have in the past,
just because I have a boy.
I thought it would, I thought maybe I'd lose a little edge,
but I didn't.
In fact, one of my teammates on this was
he said he was worried and it was very honest
of him to say that I was actually Jordan.
Very, awesome to say that,
maybe just a little worried that maybe I would bring that
missing him out onto the water.
And I had spent, the year leading up to this row
to make sure that I was emotionally ready to leave him.
And I think it did do well.
I didn't bring it in a sense that I made decisions
or I had bad days because of that.
I also was surprised that I, I still felt as,
as ready to take risks and take chances. Yeah.
That's interesting.
Maybe that will change. I don't know.
Maybe a little bit. Yeah.
I mean, I, as somebody who's got kids that are older now,
I'm aware of how that impacts,
like how I make decisions about where I invest my time,
risks, risk analysis aside,
I think as they get older and they become like,
at some point they're like, oh you're a real person.
Like, cause they develop enough,
the brains, mature a little bit
and their personality comes out a little bit more robustly.
And for me, like when they're, when they're really young,
it's harder to have that kind of not connection,
but like understanding of them as like
sentient human beings.
And then when they get to a certain point,
you're like, oh, wow,
and I just remember a shift in how I thought about things.
When was that?
I can't remember.
I mean I'm old, so it was a long time ago,
but I think maybe around you,
I think you got maybe another year and a half or so
before that starts to percolate out.
That'll be interesting.
Yeah I mean, it's already there,
but then it really kind of like gets to a different level.
Yeah.
And it changes the way that you kind of interrelate.
Yeah. I mean, I would fully expect to,
for it to change and I'm am surprised
and I'm being very honest.
Like it would have been easy for me to just sit here
and say, oh yeah, family first.
And it is family first but when I was out there
I mean, we took some risks.
We went through storms where we could have gone around.
And that's, by the way, why we broke that nine days,
we went through every single storm. We did not go around it.
That was dangerous. It was harder.
And beat us out more.
I never once thought, like,
we shouldn't be doing this because our team goal
was to go as fast as possible.
And that's, that was how you did it.
But I can see what you're saying is that
he's gonna start asking me questions.
Like, if, my, aunt twice removed says,
why don't you keep doing these things?
Or something that I'm pulling this as a fictional person
at this point, but I get those questions.
Like, why do you have to do another one?
I don't, I don't hear that.
But if my son asks me that, that'd hit a lot harder.
I think.
Yeah.
But meanwhile, you've got this consultancy,
this other business that you're running, Latitude 35.
So maybe a way that we can kind of round this out
and conclude the conversation is with some thoughts about
leadership and team building that you've learned
as a result of working with corporations and,
teaching what you've learned to business school's.
A big piece in this that I think distinguishes your
approach from other people who do similar type stuff.
Is that my sense is that it's extremely experience-based
and it's really all about kind of the emotional piece
that we were talking about earlier.
It's one thing to come in, stand on a stage and go,
here are the 10 things you need to do
to reorganize your team and motivate them.
But truly all of that remains academic
until you get a group of people out,
you make them do something hard together
and have a sort of transformative experience
that congeals them and weds them to each other
in a way that, information on its own
just isn't going to accomplish.
Yep, that's what our company's
essentially been all about is that,
you hear the other competing companies is studies show this
about leadership and building teams and surveys show that.
But largely the people that are teaching this stuff
from my experience have stood on the sidelines of,
of building teams or even been part of teams
their whole life.
They've studied them. They've read the books
and they've made maybe even written some books on it,
but they have not been out there and tested that.
And when I, when I started to,
I've been doing this for over 15 years now,
I started teaching leadership
and how to build high-performance teams.
Yeah. I have my own process.
We have our steps and whatever you want to call it,
but it constantly changes.
So every time that we add another,
add another row or another adventure,
I'm constantly tweaking it because in the end,
it's just a living document.
There's no, there's no right way to build teams.
It's not the process, it's a process.
But the most important element is that we're,
I'm going out there.
I'm building teams for different adventures.
I'm using my process best I can, but I'm making mistakes.
I'm making concessions that I'm telling people,
you shouldn't make, I'm making mistakes out there,
constantly learning from them.
And I'm bringing all that experience to our clients.
And, they've got they come with me,
with their, what their business challenges
and I'm gonna help consult them.
But we also do our most popular programs
are our experiential programs
where we take people rowing on,
on a river or sailing the British Virgin islands.
And we say, all right we are gonna teach this
by essentially putting together a team
just like I had to do and putting you out in a,
in a chaotic controlled chaotic environment,
Debbie from marketing and like Joe from sales.
Yeah. But we, when we work with a lot of,
upper management and above it's it's,
but these are people that are either,
maybe at the lowest level of coming into for the first time
leadership responsibilities.
Maybe they've never really managed people
all the way up to people that are managing people
for a long time, but are doing it a certain way, their way.
And that maybe just needs access to different perspectives.
And all we're doing is creating an environment for those,
those ideas and those experiences to happen.
And we don't sit there and placate and say,
look how you rode well together and worked as a team,
we actually dig, were very academic.
So half that experiences are that time with them
is spent in that experience with the other half
is a very academic deconstruction of that experience.
Because that's essentially what I'm doing when I debrief
my own adventures is how can I, what mistakes did I make?
How can I learn from those mistakes and move forward?
And, that's essentially what we're doing.
We're constantly being students.
I mean, you're, you're saying I'm almost at my PhD,
which I appreciate, but I'm gonna try to go for another one.
Yeah. And okay.
Since you're going to go for another one,
how do you think about communicating principles
around things like discipline, consistency,
motivation, inspiration, living your life purposeful
and, seeking your passion in terms
that gets thrown a lot around a lot,
kind of in the space of what you do.
And I'm sure, in the kind of keynote circuit speaker world,
I think it's very confusing for a lot of people
because those words are used cavalierly.
So what do they mean to you and where do you think people
should focus their energies who are trying to kind of
unlock something greater within themselves,
but feel stymied or stuck,
or just unsure about how to bring expression to that?
I think, yeah and I do a fair number of keynote speeches,
and it's hard to connect with people on keynotes.
You're on, you're on a stage and you're,
you're either telling a story or you're,
you're giving some examples and some anecdotes,
but largely the best work that I have with people on those
is afterwards when you're having dinner with them
or you're talking off stage with them and then have our
programs where we get to spend a little bit more time
making some connections.
And I think the first thing is like,
is there a willingness to change?
And I think for a lot of people,
a willingness to be a better leader
or a better builder of teams comes from the idea
that you're okay with kind of exposing yourself
and opening up your books to everybody else.
Because I used to play with all these different definitions
of leadership, and I thought, well, I'm in leadership,
so I have to have this really complex definition.
And now it's just one word it's just trust.
That's my definition.
So what's the definition of leadership? I say it's trust.
In order to build trust with the people that you're leading
and for them to build trust within themselves.
Like you have to open up your books and--
Honesty vulnerability.
Yeah, exactly.
And I think, I think one of the hardest things for us to do,
even though we talk about a lot and talk about a cliche is,
talking about our failures.
And so I spent a lot of time showing how much
we can learn from our failures.
And I think we just spent a lot of time doing that
just now on this talk.
And we, here's another cliche that drives me nuts
is that one where you hear,
it's not how many times you get knocked down
it's how many times you get back up.
And I find that to be a very unproductive cliche,
or at least incomplete at the very least.
And the reality is these days,
nobody gives a shit how many times you get back up?
Like it's just too much talent in this world.
There's so much competition. People are smart.
People are, people are getting smarter, faster
they want to learn more.
And I think we need to spend more time understanding
how we got knocked down, talking about being vulnerable,
being authentic with ourselves and with each other
so that when we do get back up, we're a tougher,
harder, stronger, smarter target to knock down again
because we need to be resilient.
This resiliency piece is so important,
but if all we're doing is proving to people
that we'll get back up I mean, we're really not getting,
we're not getting any anywhere with that.
So, if people are looking how to like really be,
be authentic leaders and how to kind of
take on some of these challenges,
I think it starts with this building the trust piece.
And I think you can spend a lot of time working on that.
So how would you begin that?
I think a lot of people, and the reason I asked that is
I think that I agree with you
completely on the vulnerability piece.
Like you cannot expect to engender trust
if you're not willing to open up your books
to use your phrasiology to be honest,
to admit where you went wrong.
I think a lot of people are intimidated to do that
or scared to do that.
It feels not safe, or it feels the kind of
conventional wisdom around that would be if I do,
if I do that, I'll appear weak
and that will be across purposes
with the trust that I'm trying to engender.
The truth is actually the opposite.
But for somebody who's never engaged in that process,
like, I guess you would have to say like start small,
but getting somebody off that ledge and into a mindset
where they're comfortable sharing on that level
with people who are underneath them
or their colleagues at work,
or even at home in their relationships,
I think is a tough row to hoe for many, many people.
And it keeps us stuck.
And it also imprisons us in our emotional states.
It paralyzes us from the growth
that we actually seek and aspire to.
Yeah.
Well, I think one of the things I've noticed about myself
is the more I've accomplished and the more of these,
of these rows, the less macho I become.
I feel that at first you feel the need,
like you're saying to kind of beat your chest
and to say, look at me, I'm on this pedestal.
And the reason why you're down there and I'm up here
is because I manage you, I lead you, I'm your boss.
And then it starts to become such a flat hierarchical
structure by the time you start to accomplish these things,
you all start to start to become on the same level.
And I think I've learned that a lot.
I felt so I felt so much the need,
like at Sonoma state to show that I am bigger
and stronger and you should be scared of me.
At one time, one of my teammates
says the only reason people row hard for you
is because they're scared of you
not because they respect you.
And that really hit me hard.
And so I've been thinking about that--
Which works in the short term,
but not in the long term.
Exactly. Yeah. It's the stick vs the carrot thing.
So if people are looking for a way to start, as you said,
a jumping off point, I start with storytelling.
Start figuring out what kind of stories you can be telling.
Forget about showing your failings for a second,
or, deciding to say, oh, this I'm gonna tell them
this is where I failed.
This is gonna be a big thing. Forget about that.
Just start, start storytelling, start a narrative.
Every time I'm telling a story, giving a keynote speech,
even if it's just with friends at a dinner,
or if it's on a stage in front of thousands of people,
I make sure that every sentence
I'm saying is for the benefit of the person listening.
Otherwise you just bloviating
and talking about something about yourself,
but if you can have other people see themselves
in the stories that you tell
you're on the road to starting those conversations
that are going to talk about the shortcomings.
And that's a way to weight in shallow,
because you're not, I'm not saying you to say,
this is where I made a mistake.
You're just telling a story.
And that encourages people to be like,
I think this one time,
you've given a fair enough fair amount of keynotes as well,
but you talk to people off stage and they want to come
and shake your hand and share stuff with you.
And I've never really identified or connected with
the macho guys that come up to me and say, oh,
I'm just like you, I hate losing.
I never, I never lose.
Which first of all, I lose all the time
so I don't identify with that.
But I just feel like they missed the whole point.
But one that happened a few years ago
that always stuck with me.
And I'll never remember what her name was
and I can picture her though.
And she wanted to share a story of her and her twin sister.
They were, they had stopped talking for years and years.
And moved away from each other.
And they finally got reconnected and put their past away.
And they decided they're gonna have,
do a century bike ride together.
And they, and she told me this story.
She goes, it's not, anxious starts.
Its nothing like what you did,
but I had the whole time that you were talking
I just kept thinking about what my sister and I did.
And we did it and it started raining and we had to get off
our bikes and walk and it took us forever,
but we finished it.
And she, and at the end she said like,
I don't even know why I'm telling you this right now.
I just felt like I wanted to say that.
I said that she,
somewhere she's out there and she doesn't realize
that has is affecting me this much
because that's successful.
I told the story that encouraged someone
to think about their stories and then share their stories.
And all of a sudden, we're a bunch of people sharing stories
and that then the vulnerabilities will come out.
But let's start with, let's start with storytelling.
Well, thanks for sharing your story with me today.
My pleasure. Thanks so much.
How's your dad. Is he good?
He's good.
He's good with you now.
Oh yeah.
All right.
In fact, we're close to the number.
I only feel comfortable saying this in front of the couple
people that listen to your podcast because we are so close.
In fact, we have a standing appointment to golf
on Monday's together.
And, and also, he's even doing a little work with me now
cause he's kind of semi-retired
so he's even starting to work at Lat 35
doing some stuff for me. So we're good.
Okay. Glad to hear it.
Yeah.
That's awesome, man.
Thanks.
Very cool. That's super inspiring what you shared today.
Everything that you're about, I'm super into.
There's so much to be learned from these experiences.
And I think the more that you're able to share them
and do it from that place of humility and vulnerability,
you become this transformative spark for so many people.
So wind in your sails.
And if there's anything I can do to support you,
I'm here to do that.
And I can't wait to see what you're gonna do next, man.
Thanks Rich, I appreciate it.
Cool. So last thing, the documentary "Chasing".
I got to see a final cut of it,
but what's the plan in terms of like it getting really like,
where are we in term? Cause we talked a lot about it today.
People are gonna be like, where do I see it so?
So, well, the thing is,
is it's so Evan Hayes and ACE productions over there,
they have it out to market.
They've had it on the market for a few months now.
They've gotten some good interest on it from a couple
of big platforms, as well as distribution, distributors.
Like I'm, I'm waiting any day for them to say,
like, they're gone in fact,
some of the meetings I'm going to tomorrow
are a way to help nudge some of these platforms over.
So I'm hoping that'll work, but he swears it'll get,
it's gonna get sold, he's never not sold this thing,
but it should end up on one of the majors,
but I've been waiting forever.
Yeah so basically just for those of you
who are watching or listening, it's not out yet.
As soon as it's out, I'll let everybody know.
If you do strike a deal in the interim
between us recording this and when it goes up,
I'll amend it and let everybody know in the show notes
where they can find it.
But in the meantime it's a TBD situation.
Yeah.
And if people want to connect with you
and follow your journey and all of that,
where's the best place to direct them.
Instagram's a great place for you to go my handle at,
Jason_T_Caldwell, follow me there.
Try to post pretty regularly.
And then, also on LinkedIn for any of the people
that wanna connect on a professional level
is a great way to find me.
And I'm always kind of posting my thoughts and articles
on there as well.
Cool, and there's a Lat 35 Instagram as well, right?
At Lat 35
@Lat35.
And especially when we're about to do our next adventure we
have someone that does a great job keeping up with that so.
Yeah cool. All right man.
Thanks for talking to me again. See you again soon.
All right.
Peace.
Bye
Plants.
(soft music)